[Music]
well hey everybody what's going on
Friday night yep DJ Maniac said hey it's
goth night here too I'm on the train in
now yeah we're going yeah we're going to
well not to the same one that DJ Maniac
is go that would be a long way yeah no
we're going to Barbarella going to
Barbarella for momento Mory yeah this
evening yep and so we're already all
pretty one of our regular listeners is
going to meet us there him and his wife
or wife or girlfriend I don't know if
they're married I think they're I think
they're
married Patrick Patrick's going to be
there they happen to be in town did he
used to be in the chat they used to be
in the chat they're at the club right
now they're at another club oh okay at
10 they're going to show up at at
Barbaro they got well it's not a club
they're they said they had to see some a
couple of
artists so I guess may maybe they're
going to an art Museum or some or a
venue live music venue maybe I don't
know yeah I
mean yeah so hopefully they can find the
place cuz Barbarella is a little hard to
find if you don't know where you're
going I told them just follow your damn
GPS it's going to take you down into
some warehouses it's like and there's no
sign yeah and uh yeah you know but
you'll figure it out
yeah Zach says Jenny you're looking
especially pale tonight why thank you
very much yeah yeah I was using a
different uh Foundation yeah is why that
I forgot I had actually cuz I was clean
in my bathroom the other day and I was
like oh yeah this is [__] full and
that was the reason that I didn't use it
before because it's a little pale for
everyday use but for going out [__] yeah
I'm going to wear it yeah um let's see
oh and he says love the lip color thank
you it's actually like three lip colors
like combined that's Patrick and his
girlfriend what dude that's that's them
okay they get a shout out yeah yeah yeah
they're supposed to come tonight like I
said I hope they can find it cuz it is
kind of a pain in the ass yeah yeah
Oracle said it's amazing what you can
find when you clutter right it's like
the other day I was at Dollar General
and I was just kind of like oh I think
I'm out of hand soap so I bought a big
thing of it and then like today I was
cleaning up and I was just like oh [__]
I already had like a full one that I
haven't even opened yet because I'm
stupid but you know what I mean I well I
have like all of those
Amazon uh
subscriptions and sometimes I forget
like which ones I have like I canceled a
lot of them because I had one for like
shampoo and conditioner and I ended up
with like a ridiculous I had a closet
full of shampoo and conditioner I'm like
clearly I did not use enough shampoo and
conditioner for me to get like a box of
it every two months because it was just
piling up so I stopped that one but you
know I still I use shampoo for soap too
so that's kind of good but holy [__] use
it for bath so yeah you know yeah cuz
it's it's it's dual purpose and the and
conditioner is good for like shaving
your legs and stuff so I use that for
that too like yeah I wash my hair and
[__] but I don't wash it every single
day I probably wash it every other day
because otherwise it gets
all gets all yucky you know what I mean
yeah so um what what was I GNA say man I
was going to say something and I forgot
all about it Zach says have you ever
done your brows with crazy colors since
you draw them on mine are thin as [__]
and I hate it also they don't move much
so I always have RBF a rusting [__]
face I've never um I don't think I've
ever put them on like put different
colored eyebrows on have I no not that I
remember like sometimes I'll do black
and then like I've done like hot pink
like underneath or white underneath or
something like that but I don't think
I've ever made the actual eyebrows like
a different color I don't know why like
I never really thought of doing
that maybe someday but I tried to grow
my back like when was it like a year or
two ago and I grew them back for a while
and then I was like there were such a
pain in the ass that I was like oh yeah
now I remember why I shaved them off in
the first place it's a pain to draw them
on but it's a bigger pain to like pluck
them and keep them looking pluck them
pluck them like a chicken yeah I pluck
them like a
chicken um y'all GNA have to see what
Jen's wearing tonight man she's looking
fantastic she's wearing a black
seethrough dress with some bad ass
little [__] badass little [__]
booty shorts and and [__] stockings
and [__]
boots I have to I'll have to activate
porn cam here in a minute activate porn
cam oh I should make like a little video
thing for that activate the porn cam
activate see it I'm going show okay okay
I'm going to activate porn cam activate
porn cam well it's not really porn cam
let not don't get too excited yeah well
let me like stand up cuz there's a I'm
all crunched up turn the light on get a
good angle cuz I can't [__] see what
it looks like I can't see what it looks
like honestly get this hold on man I'm
trying to get enough Slack in here there
you go t
yeah hold on how how does this thing
look at that oh you know why the cats
did not long enough the cats did that
cats did that yeah so there's some
cleavage action okay so kind of porn can
yeah porn can turn
around see I'm an expert at shooting
this yet man look at that you going to
get some some angle in the back give me
some back arch there Jen oh like Tom
Hardy just like Tom Hardy hold on just
like some Tom Hardy right uh no you
turning away too much turn sideways I'm
GNA trying to get a profile shot other
way other way other other way see look
at that there you go there you go you're
ridiculous of course I'm
ridiculous are we gonna are we going to
talk about your about about your um your
thing no okay we'll tuck that back under
there cuz that's right where my foot has
to go all right yeah yeah uh Bambi came
in here the other day and she and your
the porn laptop was leaned up like that
the porn laptop well that's what we
watch
porn but um but she came in and she
accidentally like bumped into it and it
fell over and she freaked the [__] out
okay so yes and it's it's tied all the
damn cables
[Laughter]
got Zach said I love that I started the
Tom Hardy meme in here yeah yeah yeah I
I still cannot believe that
that Arch man that's
amazing I really like that photo I'm I'm
going to keep that looks like is that
Miss Lee from Korea saying she loves
yeah she loves your dress how you doing
Miss
Lee DJ Maniac said at least you don't
have chronic [__]
face
yeah yeah [__] Thomas a Steven
Spielberg of porn directing of
course Jay's trying to get me to talk
about my gay underwear
I got the gayest underwear of all time
you really do I mean it looks good but
it is like the gayest underwear ever
yeah it's professional
underwear it's got Zach's gonna love
this [__] first of all it's got a Cod
piece M all right and then it's got It's
got pockets in the back of the underwear
where you can put foam pads in yeah to
get and what it does it makes you booty
pop yeah and I I wear it because it
keeps my pants on yeah cuz I wear real
lowrise pants I wear real they kind of
low they're like super lowrise so I got
to have like a little bit more so they
don't fall down I have like a little bit
more when you bend over yeah like that
so they don't fall off I'll show
youall uhoh Are you seriously taking
your pants off right now oh my God it's
so early yeah yeah look at that it's
just gay as look look at how gay that is
look at this sh it's got a [__] C
piece it's got a C piece in there show
you see look at that
look at that [__] [__] oh my God it's
so early so what it does is it's so
early I'm so glad I did I'm so glad that
I didn't um that I didn't do the uh the
sponsor on this show hold hold hold and
then in the back in the back it's got
that [__] it's got a [__] pads in
little boot sticking out yeah DJ Maniac
said thirst trap Tom it's a thirst trap
it's it's a [__] multinational thirst
trap I got girls in Korea
looking don't right Miss
Lee you yeah L said it's not PG-13 now
no no this sh's already it never ises
this show is like I because like I said
if you were here on Wednesday like we
actually have but they're not NE like
exactly sponsors but we do like
affiliate stuff now and I was thinking
about doing one at the beginning of the
show and I was like you know what we
better not because this I know how this
shit's going to go and we might get in
but you know what weird you know we did
the Wednesday night show which was about
a serial killer obviously and about a
dude that like beheaded chicks and stuff
no no ad restrictions no isn't that
mystifying but yet like other things we
do like there's ad restrictions on stuff
that seems to like not make any sense
but then we do shows about serial
killers and it's fine I don't know I
don't get it but whatever whatever I
think it's just AI doing it and article
says wow we aren't even paay for this
that's right normally yall have to pay
for that [__] you know Tom you are such
a cheap you a cheap I'm a [__] hoe
you're a cheap I'm online I'm I'm online
ho man
hoing you are kind of man H yeah a
little bit a little bit it's all fun and
game it is
yeah I do it because I like it not cuz I
need
[Laughter]
it it is kind of fun I just wish it
wasn't so much waiting around you know
got waiting around too much it is kind
of so it is kind of boring
yeah because I'm just sitting there
going wow it could something waiting for
some dude from England to show up and go
I'm really
horny I'm at
work just put on a good show I I don't
care what you guys do M yeah which is
really that's how you deal with Cam
camera
people cam
performers don't tell them what you want
just say have a good time give me a good
show and you're going to get a better
show
thank you Bryce yeah what did Bryce say
for Tom's thirst trap L yeah thirst trap
thirst tra all the way thirst Trapp all
the way down in New Zealand all right
got damn ma repaying me okay facial
tattoos and [__] get ready to do the
[__] Warrior dance and just pop out
to Cod piece anding CH Ching money comes
that made me really that that her
[__] club [__]
CL that made me laugh when you took the
cie thing out yeah that was like pretty
funny cuz he's like look it's just in a
pocket Yeah well yeah I mean the butt
ones are like that too the funny thing
about those jockmail underwear they they
do look really uh cool but like I think
that like the Amazon store do you get
them from Amazon right get from Amazon
and Sheen has them yeah and or not Shen
or maybe it's teu I mean they're they're
good quality they are actually they're
kind they're expensive but they're
really well made and they look really
nice but they are very they're very very
specifically targeted to a gay audience
so yeah they have gay models that say
you know what I mean that say [__]
weird homosexual stuff on the tags what
was the what was the one that had like
the tag oh I'm trying to remember what
it was it was actually like pretty gross
but yeah it was gross it was nasty well
I mean not gross but you know what it
had to do with uh uh fluids yeah how how
the underwear should be soaked in fluids
like you can imagine it was a whole
bunch of [__] cuz I'm like reading that
going wow that's um yeah yeah okay
they're not all they're not some of them
were specifically targeted towards gay
audience other ones are more neutral you
know um where it doesn't really the
coloring and The Styling you know it's
just more for they're just a a real good
quality men's underwear uh for that kind
they have a couple different models you
know they even got jock straps they got
that I got one of those yeah he does
have one of those yeah it's black and
red with his little booty sticking out
booty in yeah yeah yeah Jenny loves that
[__] um cuz then I tell him to turn
around like come on it's work yeah yeah
she trying to give me a t then she
tries got to run away from her you know
she's coming at me with some kind of
object coming at you with an object yeah
she's like you stay here you know you
stay right you are you be still give me
the back arch that's back arch give some
Tom Hardy action but no
um the ones I just showed you that was
kind of like the mid price ones they got
like a another pair that I have that was
like top of the line got like like it's
it's black but they have white
highlights White Band more printing on
them the materials a little a couple
more PES in it and it's like a stretchy
material with little fine holes in it
like from uh Sports type material and uh
man everything breathes really well they
they it Wicks away moisture yeah what's
funny is that you know you wear
underwear all day man that's just nasty
you know uh [__] by the end of the
day not these it's like they're [__]
like you just put them on I don't I
don't know what it is they don't they
don't [__] they smell just like you
just put them on you know what I me you
smelling your own underwear Tom well you
know you're checking it you know I mean
[__] yeah CU I do that too I'm like
can I wear these again no I don't
usually do that even even if I have
underwear on for like an hour or two I'm
just like yeah I'm going to get a new
pair been times like [__] man these
things it's like I just put them on I
had them on all day these still smell
okay yeah the now I'll do that with like
pants or a shirt or something if I only
wore it for an hour or two but
absolutely not I was to we way
the but the top shit's like $40 a pair
yeah that's a lot I didn't realize that
they were that expensive but they are
like really really nice quality though I
have to say yeah they're built a last
yeah the ones I just showed you were the
cheaper ones they were probably about 30
yeah Zach said if Tom thinks he's a
predator he should come hang out at the
gay bar I go to during pride month cuz
holy [__] that [__] better be called
the
manhole the
manhole the ram
rod I would totally go to a club called
the ram rod yeah
that sounds like super fun actually I
used to like to go to gay bars back in
the day yeah a lot of women like to go
to gay
bars well goth clubs are gay bars well
that's true kind of kind of kind of kind
of well they're kind of just like an
like all weirdos does matter like if
you're a weirdo okay yeah we don't care
what it's it's it's a whole spectrum of
weirdos just
whoever and entertainment people yeah
grur says I used to have mesh underwear
but it kept getting caught on my Prince
Albert stud talk about ouch yeah yeah
they're they're like mesh yeah it's like
a stretchy
mesh I can understand that because I
have to watch what I wear too because I
get [__] like caught on my nipple rings
yeah all the time so it's like if I
can't like for the um like when we
stream and stuff I can't really wear cuz
I have kind of all these sort of fish
nety kind of little outfit like body
stockings and stuff and I can't wear
them like without a bra yeah because the
[__] is just G to catch and then if I
try to pull it it's just like yeah for
those you don't know I I did Jen's
Pierce put two bars in there and they
have they have beads on the end and the
ones she has on right now they have like
a semicircular moon piece of metal
hanging on yeah like a half ring like a
half ring so's bars and half of a ring
they're nice I like them yeah they're
they're they're cute yeah although I
fainted when he changed them
yeah sexy [__] man slave slave girl [__]
man yeah s love that it's like something
out of a
damn Arabic [__]
Harum I've been thinking about doing the
nose too but I can't really decide nah I
mean not septum no I wasn't going to do
that I do have some kind of like fake
like lip rings that are fake you know
what I mean cuz I just wanted to see how
that would look yeah I kind of like
those the only problem with those is
that the fake ones you know you got to
watch because like when you're drinking
like beer like out of a can or something
like that like a lot of times they fall
out or actually like last time we went
to momento I had them in and they didn't
open until like they opened a half hour
later for whatever reason so we're like
well [__] it we so we went to 7-Eleven
and got sandwiches and then I was eating
sandwiches I lost one of my lip rings
and I thought I'd swallowed it yeah but
I found it eventually it was just in my
life I got a bunch more rings and more
piercing stuff I can do lips if you want
yeah
I don't know I don't know that's a lot
easier because that's very small gauge
yeah well like I said anything is after
going through that like getting my
nipples pierced it's like wow after that
I'm never going to do something like a
tongue no I imagine that shit's hard as
[__] but probably pops and cracks when
it goes through there I'm not going to
do that I don't want my tongue pierced
anyway that just seems like it would be
a pain in the ass I thought the nipples
would be a pain in the ass and it was it
is kind of but I got used to it yeah
like you just have to like be care
like when you get out of the shower and
you're like drying off of the towel you
can't like knock the towel into or like
you know pull the towel across it
because it'll catch so you really have
so you just kind of have to watch what
you're doing that's all and I kind of
got used to it now so it's not so bad
it's not so
bad um Zach says I think the weirdest
porn I ever saw was a dude with the
physique of a heroin addict getting
fisted by a bear type dude wearing
nothing but a bow tie and talking like
the like a character from far
girl I'm gonna look that
up that sounds really interesting yeah
what's the movie Jen will find it what
yeah I'll find it yeah I'm sure it' be
hard to find that one well I don't know
maybe
not Danny Rowling said mesh underwear is
like you fishing and catching your own
package every
time Zach says you should do one of
those little studs on the side of your
nostril my sister has one of those and
it's really cute just a stud yeah maybe
yeah yeah yeah not necessarily a ring
yeah Zach says oh I have that scene
bookmarked I can send it to you yeah
send it to J watch I want to see that
yes I'll watch it Tom probably won't
watch he he don't want to watch it but
I'll watch it guess I just like I can
imagine it already going okay yeah I'm
fascinated by I'm fascinated by that
gu we haven't seen any really good porn
lately though I was we were just kind of
watching to yeah not really we were kind
of watching The Animated stuff but yeah
didn't we have the animated stuff on the
other night yeah that running in the
background yeah yeah that well that's
like a compilation and I like that one
cuz it's long you know what I mean so
you can just kind of put it on in the
background and have it all kind of going
on it's like two hours or
something um Danny Rowling said if you
pierce your tongue wrong you could die
so yeah yeah probably lose a bunch of
blood yeah I think that bleeds a lot and
like I said I never had the desire to
have that done so you don't have to
worry about that I don't really want
that I don't want to do that you know
what I'm saying yeah um but yeah so oh
remember okay I did remember I wrote it
down here was one thing that I wanted
toing I've been wanting to bring this up
on the show for like a really long time
and I keep forgetting so here's this
weird well you know it's not a huge
thing but it's kind of like a little
mystery in this area where we live oh
yeah we got to try to do a show about
this maybe yeah I don't know if we can
do a whole show about it we're going to
have to like research it well maybe we
could solve it maybe so maybe so so
every time like when we go to the
Chinese buffet we're on this road it's
kind of like a little bit of rural rural
road like for part of it and at this one
stage there is like a sign on the side
like a homemade sign on the side of the
road and it says what was what did it
say the first time we saw it kitten has
claws kitten has claws kitten I love you
something like that yeah something like
that so it always says kitten something
something so we saw this sign and I was
like that's weird I wonder what that
means cuz it's just like a random sign
like a wooden sign on the side of the
road in the woods that's been painted
spray painted over and then black the
background's black and then they spray
paint in white usually yeah either that
or it's like a that chalkboard paint and
they write on it with chalk but it looks
like
paint the signs not not very big it's
about that big but it's on the side of
the road and um every time we pass it
every few weeks the message on it's
different but it's always to kitten yeah
kitten Fights Back kitten has claws
kitten I love you happy Birthday kitten
happy birthday kitten [__] like
that it's like kind of creepy yeah and
like we keep P it doesn't change every
week but probably like every three two
three weeks like it'll say something
different yeah and it's just a wooden
sign so Jen went
online and just put in kitten has claw
sign and K on the name of the road cu
the the name of that like little town is
Grand Island yeah and evidently other
people were asking about it on Reddit
it's it's been going on for over 10
years yeah there was an article about it
like I only found like one article about
it that was in like some local like
magazine or something and it was from
the article was from several years ago
and when the article was from they said
it had been going on for 10 years like
at that point like people have been
asking about it so it's been going on
for a long time or like 15 years yeah so
I'm just kind of like so every time we
pass it it said kitten has claws today
yeah when we passed it but like every
time we go by there I'm always like what
is the [__] story behind that like
you know me cuz I always write about
true crime and [__] like that to me I'm
picturing somebody whose daughter
disappeared like 20 years ago
and they're putting that sign out there
for them like for some reason like I
don't know why that was the first thing
that occurred to me but you know Tom's
like well maybe it's not anything that
you know weird but I don't know it just
seems really creepy to me the
handwriting looks like a man's
handwriting it does
yeah and it's not particularly
good it's done quickly whoever's doing
it is doing it at night I guess no we
were thinking about like putting a trail
cam up yeaha to see who it was that was
doing it it's got to be whoever owns
that property but I don't know there's
you can't see a house cuz there's it's
just the side of the road and then it's
just a field it's just like a field yeah
and there I think there's a little Trail
like back there but maybe there's a
house back there but I don't know you do
is go down
there see where that trail goes and what
house that is what house is on that
property at least you'll know who lives
there you have to be careful though cuz
it might be a crazy person and they'll
shoot
you I don't
know who knows that's what I mean you
don't it just seems very odd it's a very
odd somebody trying to get attention I
guess so it's like so I didn't know if
it was committ to it though yeah because
it it changes like we saw it the first
time we went to the buffet which was a
while back and we saw it the first time
and I was like wow that's weird and then
like I think it said the same thing the
following week but then it changed like
the week after that and I was like hey
look like it says something different
and it's like somebody's coming out here
and changing the sign and I was just
kind of like what the [__] is that all
about I don't think it's for a
person I think it for it is for a
kitten I think it's for a
cat that person might be a cat lady in
there she might have a bunch of cats and
it's just a statement towards cats I
don't know today you said that it's like
well maybe it's a crazy guy and that's
and like his that's what he called his
ex-wife yeah yeah it might have been
that and he's like saying he still loves
her yeah it might be that or something I
don't know I was thinking of the guy who
built Coral c Coral Castle yeah he was
kind of like that he said he built that
for some girl who dumped him right which
wow when she was
16 yeah she was 16 and he was uh 20s in
his 20s or 30s I think he was too old
for that was a strange dude I think we
did a show on that guy if we haven't we
should I think we did do a show about
like weird Florida Mysteries but and I
thought we covered it on there but that
was a long time ago so I don't remember
it wasn't an american guy it was a guy
that moved from Eastern Europe came here
and he was a little bitty guy like five
feet tall he was little and he built
that an entire
castle out of uh some kind of rock what
Cina CA yeah and had a whole garden and
a rocking horse and everything or a moon
that you could Rock in it like a rocking
chair it's crazy and like a door that
swings like all the way around it's all
Stone big too it's super weird I think
he was from
um wasn't he from the same place Nicola
Tesla was from oh now I can't remember I
know we talked I know we talked about
that from Croatia oh maybe I think he
was from Croatia or something that's a
weird [__] story yeah I can't imagine
being that bothered by somebody leaving
you that you would construct a whole
entire thing like that like how does
that what is the even connective tissue
between be [__] maybe he's just like
well I needed to a reason that kind of
sounded I don't know well one of one of
the stories I heard said that he was
talking about that girl who dumped him
that and he was building that as to like
get her back kind of deal right like
how's that supposed to prove his love
for her but uh evidently U and it was
wasn't a girl in the United States I
think she's back in Croatia I think but
see that's what dude that's what that
dude didn't understand it's like you do
that for a girl yeah and she'd be like
oh so you're crazy then well here I'm
going to make it even worse than he was
doing this after he was after he was
married already to some other chick yeah
and I'm sure his wife was super thrilled
about that why are you building that oh
no reason buing this for this other
chick yeah she will come back and she's
like okay well I'm going to leave you
too bye you're not going to build that
[__] for me I'm sure all right I'm out
of here he might have been bullshitting
though yeah that's the thing I mean
that's crazy it's hard to know it's hard
to know what's true when you deal with
people who are crazy that yeah yeah
gther said it's someone who has too much
spare time and likes being creepy yeah I
guess so like I said just on its surface
it doesn't seem creepy but I don't know
I thought it was creepy to me like I
said the first place my brain went was
this is their daughter and their
daughter disappeared or ran away and
they don't know where they are and so
they keep putting this sign out there
like hoping that they'll see it for some
reason like I said and that might be
just because you know I read a lot of
True Crime so that was the first place
my brain went but it could be completely
innocuous but I don't really know I
wouldn't have to set up a shop somebody
saying that I should set up Che and C
catch him I wouldn't have to I could
just put a a trail cam on that thing
yeah I think Tammy said that too yeah
when they come that's what we were
thinking it would just capture them or I
could just go to the house that's on
that
property and uh it's a local mystery
just go in there and say uh
are you the one writing all the signs
the kitten has claws and [__] I'd have a
[__] body cam on and see see how they
react if they denied it I wouldn't
believe them I mean they have to know
that everyone's kind of curious well I'm
curious and obviously other people were
curious too because there was an article
about it a few years ago because
everybody's like what the [__] is that
right that's like so weird and like I
said they're obviously still doing it
because it changes every few
weeks like I said I think it says kitten
has claws now no it's now it says kitten
I love you yeah I think it does it said
kitten has claws it said that more than
once it had yeah last week it also said
kitten I love you but before that it
said kitten has cloth yeah and it has
said that more than once like it's
changed out so that's they're recycling
the same phrase I don't know it's
Bizarro um Gen X Jason says Jenny and
Tom bow house Peter Murphy Solo or Love
and Rockets bow house all day yeah yeah
I like well and honestly I like Peter
Murphy's solo stuff too up until about
uh I'm gonna say Cascade yeah although
um dust was good too although it took a
while to grow on me but um I like love
and& Rockets as well but I think like
after they got real famous like after
the you know love and& Rockets album
that had so alive on it I was like kind
of not as they went a little mainst
streamy let me check if Miss Le I like
Express though that's probably my no
well yeah Express is probably my
favorite let me check if Miss Lee is
still with it Miss Lee when you listen
to the show are you in Korea or are you
in the United States and when we start
talking about music like he asked us
about Peter Murphy Ling Rockets or or B
house do you have any idea what we're
talking
about I don't know I didn't know I don't
know if we lose some of our
International audience well there's
probably a lot of Americans that don't
know [__] well yeah that's what I
mean so it's like I don't worry about it
too much because you know probably like
some Americans like who the [__] is that
what are you talking about Danny Rowling
said did Jenny and Tom ever see the film
burnt offerings [__] yeah I I love that
movie I read the book several times too
the novel is also good and if so was
there ever an old lady that was living
in the upstairs room or was it a ghost
just wondering we talked about that um
here's the thing in the movie like sorry
if you haven't seen it but it came out
in the 70s so come on um in the movie
they kind of imply that there wasn't
really anybody in the room and that
Karen Black like kind of took over the
role of that like or was possessed by
whatever was in there in the book it's a
lot clearer that whatever is in that
room is not a person it's kind of
like and maybe I'm reading into it but
my interpretation was whatever's in that
room is like the force that is animating
the house cuz like the H the house is
like a living entity it's the spiritual
heart of the house right it's like an
evil spirit spirit and slightly in
another dimension kind of like uh cuz
didn't you say it was just a white room
a white room she opened it and it was
just like a white light in there yeah
and it was the life force that of the
house that was vampiring people
basically so it could rebuild itself
yeah which you know which is another
take on I love burnt offerings by the
way the book and the movie that's
another take on two other stories kind
of like that one of them being The
Shining with the the spirit that ran the
hotel the Overlook
that was something kind of like that
even the even the um the guy that was
the ghost that was running the Overlook
he wasn't the Overlook he was just the
main guy wasn't he you never actually
talked to the Overlook yeah in the book
I don't believe not that I remember it's
been several years since I've read the
novel yeah the Grady Grady not Grady uh
the guy who was the bartender Lloyd
Lloyd Lloyd is not the hotel I think
he's just the uh the the head ghost yeah
kind of thought he was just like the
representative yeah he's the head that
was how I he's the head ghost in charge
of it serving it I don't think he's the
hotel if I remember correctly and then
there's another
movie was called the
evil where that was 1978 I think 1978
which I love that I saw that in the
theater that's a really good movie I
feel like it's underrated I saw that in
the theater when I was a little kid my
babysitter Kimmy took me to see it oh
Kimmy yeah she was so cute that she
taking me to see it she's about 13 12
she's probably about 12 when she and Tom
was like a little bitty time yeah I was
a little kid a tomet i well it what year
was that 78 that movie came out I would
have been either eight or nine
yeah but
um in that
one people go into this haunted I think
it was a resort that they were going to
turn into some kind of a uh getaway for
trebled teens some [__] like that yeah
weren't they tur into like a school or
like some kind of Educational Center or
something like
it's been a while since I've seen it and
at the very end you find out that
there's a couple of ghosts one of them
is a good guy who built the place and
the other one is uh some evil ghosts
that
are trying to unleash the devil who's
entrapped in the in in another
dimension in the basically basically the
basement of the hotel if I remember
correctly wasn't it like the basement
part of the hotel yeah yeah down on the
floor yeah they had a big door with like
sealed off with crosses and [__] yeah
the guy who built the place I think was
in a guy who was a Christian guy who was
in The Occult I think he was sealing
away the devil well that's kind of just
keep him in I think it it was either an
a demon or the devil or an evil force I
don't think it actually says who it is
but when you see him he's got horns and
he's in a suit and he tries to talk his
way out into freedom and everything so
he definitely looks like the devil but
he might have just been the the evil
life force of the house impersonating
the devil so it's kind of
open to it
so the burn the 70s had a lot of that
yeah that was like very much in the
there was a lot of movies like that and
a lot of them were good honestly if I
had to like narrow down my very very
favorite sub genre of horror it'
probably be like 70s Haunted House
movies yeah I don't know why I just I
love them so much and um Joseph brought
up Legend of Hell House is another movie
of that type yeah same and I also love
Legend of Hell House and that novel is
great too that's written by Richard mat
but I think like the granddaddy or
grandmother of them all actually is
Haunting of Hill House by Shirley
Jackson that came out in 1959 that novel
yeah and I think she was I don't know if
she was the one that introduced the
concept of kind of like the hungry house
or like a house that manipulated uh the
emotions of everybody in it so it could
like feed off them but that's I think
that's where like a lot of the
subsequent um novels and movies that
came out out that are like that are a
lot of them are kind of homaging that
yeah you know what I'm saying Miss Lee
Kings B says I was washing my hair Tom
yeah okay okay but I asked are you in
the United States or or or are you in
Korea that's what I wanted to know oh
okay I thought she was in said she was
in Korea last time I thought she said
she was in Korea yeah said she said
hello from South Korea South Korea yeah
yeah I would imagine yeah I don't even I
don't know what time it is in South
Korea it must be like a big difference
it's probably a big difference yeah yeah
cuz it's 8 p.m. it's 8 in the evening
it's 8 8 8 at night here yeah Danny ring
said the ending of burnt offerings sort
of reminded me of the Sentinel which Al
that's also a great movie yeah which I
would love to see yeah we reviewed it a
while back a couple years ago um which I
would love to see a modern sequel with
Christina Reign's character coming back
yeah that would actually be pretty cool
that one I don't know if I'd do a remake
necessarily but yeah you could totally
do a do a sequel to that I mean that was
kind of like a whole there's a whole
Universe you could explore there really
yeah burn offerings had Karen black in
it though sexy ass sexy assen black and
it also had Oliver Reed yeah Oliver Reed
[__] wrestle you naked in front
of a [__] I mean he didn't do it in
that movie unfortunately on other movies
he did that was women in love yeah I'm
pretty sure yeah which I also saw which
is also a great movie it's not a horror
movie I wouldn't mind going back in time
meeting Oliver Reed in the bar you and
Oliver Reed I feel like would vibe that
[__] would [__] vibe you know we're
drunk as [__] cuz I know that that dude
would [__] drink me out of the table
oh big time and then he tries to wrestle
me naked by the fireplace like in that
[__] and you if you were drunk enough
you might be like all right because I I
know what you're doing and then I'd be
over there kind of drunk but I'd be like
I saw this movie Jen pull the camera out
like Zach could be directing yeah I'm
I'm I'm keeping this for he put his
director's scarf on Zach his little
glasses and his beanie
the old school
Hollywood yeah those little pants with
like the yeah little pants that [__]
po out like that the little the little
the little horse riding pants yeah the
cone that you yell through yeah the
little
cone Zach says God I love women in love
that's a great [__] movie I love that
movie too Danny Rowling said it's uh
10:06 a.m. in South Korea okay it's
10:00 in the morning so it's already
tomorrow okay that's why she's watching
her hair wait is is it tomorrow is it
yesterday or is it this morning I don't
know is it later or
earlier Joseph says are you familiar
with the 1983 horror board game
Nightmare House it is A Haunted House
war game I've heard of it but I don't
think I never had it and never played it
I did have some kind of um when I was
little I did have some kind of creepy
board games I had one I had one called
Mystery Mansion which I [__] Lov I
think I might have had that one and I
had one called which witch which I think
was also called haunted house but it was
the same game I think I had some board
games there for kids yeah that were like
haunted house board games but it's been
so long I hav I don't remember them I
don't remember I just remember I had
some of that kind of stuff yeah they
were good when you were a kid they
probably would be bored CU even when I
was little I mean anything that was like
creepy I was like yeah buy me that there
was one I started to play we used to
play it at Military Academy was
stro we love that
one I loved risk
also I never got into risk you never got
itigo and I liked Battleship I liked
Battleship also yeah me and my brother
used to play that all the time we had
all kind of like [__] board games but
um yeah I liked the I liked the horrory
ones and then video games came in and
all that [__] went away yeah and then
everybody then we all started playing
The Legend of Zelda on Nintendo you know
what I mean well actually at First we
had we didn't even have like we were too
poor to have a um a s so we had an
odyssey which was like a kind of a
knockoff ofar the thing is I think
Odyssey was at the same price though I
don't know I thought it was a little bit
cheaper I think it was the same price I
can't really remember it the American
competition and it had better graphics
actually than Atari and when they came
out because my dad bought one and he
gave it to he bought that one over the
Atari because the salesman kind of
convinced him that the games were better
and that that it was an American company
so I get commission well Atari I think
was an American company too though if I
remember yeah I think that was from
California it sounded Japanese but it
was American but it was so early on in
the
game um some people thought Odyssey was
going to end up being a better system
yeah when we saw how that worked out
with VHS and betamax right yeah um but
the thing is is neither one of them was
really that good because what ended up
happening was like in television came
out and then kico Vision came out boom
both oh I remember that one yeah kico
Vision was better than both we didn't
have that either I think we just had had
Odyssey and then when the first Nintendo
came out we got that
yeah but in television was good remember
that one yeah we didn't have it but I
had a friend that had it yeah that L
that looked really good there was a much
better graphics compared to the other
two but it was expensive the games were
expensive too and they didn't make as
many of them and it quickly got replaced
by kico vision from what I remember and
that had games like Donkey Kong on it
and they looked exactly pretty to to my
eyes back then they looked just like the
arcade games they probably don't now
because the standards are are you know
my standards are a lot higher now than
what they used to be but they look good
for a home system [__] it's just
hilarious like how happy we were with
stuff that nowadays it's just like it
looks it now looks like complete crap
well blew me away I guess that was in I
don't know '96
might have been 97 I guess I got that
[__]
N64 man I love that game had uh bond007
golden eye man that was the first
[__] shoot first person shooter it
was the [__] they finally released it
for [__] Xbox One and I got it I
still play it I love and it's so much
easier with two joysticks yeah because
yeah N64 didn't have two two joysticks I
had one and a bunch of buttons the
control for N64 wasn't that good yeah
cuz he has a bunch of like old video
games too like and then they came out
with Rogue Squadron a [__] good
Flying Star Wars game I loved it I even
had the [__] RAM boost [__]
cartridge to make the graphics a little
bit better and then they like you're
talking about Zelda they had the um
Legend of Zelda Ocarina of Time oh yeah
man that was that's kind of like yeah
blew my [__] everybody loved that
[__] game and I love that game that's
like an iconic it took a long time to
solve it when you did I was I didn't buy
buying those cheat books and [__] I try
to solve it myself you know some of
those puzzles like the one with the
dancing dude in the [__] windmill
that took me a long time to F to figure
that one out I liked Zelda but as far as
like the Nintendo goes I think my
favorite game was probably Castlevania
and then we had a um Sega as well and I
liked Sonic the Hedgehog like I played
that a lot okay Miss Lee says that it's
it's Saturday morning in Korea yeah okay
so she's in Kore so you're talking to us
from the future from the future you're
talking to us from the future we haven't
even gone out to the club yet yeah I
mean yeah what are you doing on a
Saturday in
Korea yeah let's find out Gen X Jason
said Jenny and Tom is the sign behind
you made out of metal yes yes it is um
Our Friend Sophie who is sometimes in
the chat here and sometimes she's on the
show and sometimes is on the show
because she comes to visit us sometimes
she's from Michigan she sent us that for
a wedding present yeah and it's cool as
[__] yeah and you can change you can
change CH the colors you can get them to
[__] morph into other colors and it
looks great the thing is though it [__]
up the autofocus yeah like every time
the color changes like the the camera
goes blurry so I was like well let's
just leave it on there because that's
that that blue is like that's the best
color the best color on being able to
see it but
yeah yeah limb said maybe it's 900 p.m.
where thas it's actually a quarter past
eight it's quarter past eight yeah zel
yeah Zelda it was uh Zelda
Legend of Zelda Ocarina of Time for
Nintendo 64 I think that was back in
199 six or seven yeah I can't remember
when that came out that time I loved
that game it's all a blur yeah when you
get to our age yeah I know it was I know
it was late later
90s I remember stuff real good until
like about
1992 like if you ask cuz Tom will asked
me all the time what year did that album
come out or whatever and I immediately
know but after 1992 everything is kind
of just kind of like starts blend
blending together yeah weird which and I
wasn't even that old in 1992 I mean I
graduated from I was what 20 I was 20
yeah in 1992 but after that I was just
kind of like I don't really remember so
maybe I don't know maybe um parasites
are eating that part of my brain I don't
really know I don't know I I have mad
cow or something I don't really know but
I just remembered when N64 came out
Nintendo 64 came out that was the first
time I was really happy with a home
system that a home system could compete
with a or and beat sometimes in a ways
an arcade system we grew up in a time we
had to go to Arcade stand up and play
them things which I still do nowadays we
got it's still fun to do that yeah but
um yeah I actually like to go like we we
went to um when we go to Will's Pub for
a while they had an arcade cabinet of M
Pac-Man
yeah and I was like and I play that all
the time cuz man I used to love I used
to love back something about standing up
next to a console and playing
it it's it's it's a it's kind of a retro
experience for us older people I guess I
don't know I don't you know if young
people understand it maybe they do but
yeah there really doesn't seem to be any
I mean like a lot a lot of younger
people seem to be into kind of the older
games too so like I said I don't know if
it's
I don't know if it's the same yeah they
were pretty hard they were they were
hard they were hard yeah
um but no that N64 was the first home
system where it was worth owning because
I also had that [__]
Sega I had Sega before that se Sega what
was it called Sega Genesis yeah we had
that too and that had good games on it
man Sonic was really good yeah I used to
really like Sonic actually they were hit
and miss sometimes you get a Japanese
game that looks cheesy as [__] the
packaging and you'd buy it and you You'
love it now was Metroid Sega or no that
was that was Nintendo right no what was
Metroid Metroid was on on Super Nintendo
okay I think oh I loved Metroid yeah I
remember that one that was Metroid and
Castlevania were probably myv Mega Man
Too was also Super Nintendo yeah Zach
says I hate the aesthetic of most things
from the 9s and early 2000s you and me
both um I really don't and I can't
exactly put my finger on it but you know
coming at it from like a horror movie
point of
view there were some good horror movies
that came out in the '90s and the early
2000s however most of them sucked donkey
balls donkey balls well no they were
just kind of like a lot of them were
just like shitty remakes it's like hey
let's remake The Texas Chainsaw Massacre
but with
like perfect looking hot people and it's
just kind of like it didn't work this it
was okay like it wasn't terrible but
it's just kind of like it didn't like
make me want to shower afterward like
the original did you know what I mean it
just wasn't scuzzy yeah it just looked
too everything looked
too glossy everything looked too perfect
um I didn't like a lot of the music from
that era either um the '90s in
particular when we were at mannequins
last week and they played uh the Marilyn
Manson cover of sweet dreams yeah and I
was just kind of like God the 90s were
so [__] try hard it was just such a
try hard decade everyone was just trying
to be extreme and crazy and weird and it
was just like and it just gave me a
headache that was the mainstream though
there was there was some stuff I thought
from that era that was really good like
I liked Massive Attack I really like the
Shirley Manson from garbage from that
time well yeah I like that too [__]
there's good [__] from every era I'm not
saying that bork was really good in the
yeah I like her too I like sugar cubes
better than her solar solo stuff I like
her solo stuff too say solo stuff is
also good um
okay Miss Lee said she used to play
Super Mario yeah okay you must yeah I
like I like super Super Mario well Miss
Lee must be around our age and I liked
Super Mario Kart yeah like where you me
and my brother used to play that yeah
she also knew Sonic yeah yeah sonic was
on Genesis Sega Genesis yeah cuz we had
both we had a Super Nintendo when we had
a Sega Genesis like later on like in the
90s or whenever it came out she say
something was a very cheap looking
horror movie what I don't know what
you're talking about what's Missle very
cheap looking horror like from the '90s
and 2000s oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
cuz Zach was saying especially movies
they look so damn flat and boring and
everything is beige yeah it's just like
everything is just very generic and it's
like let's put these like generic hot
people in this movie and it's just they
remade everything like from the 70s and
80s and 99% of them were forgettable not
terrible but forgettable and it's just
kind of like I think the worst one maybe
I don't know I don't know if I want to
say the worst one but The Nightmare on
Elm Street remake
was that was unfortunate man like
they how can you have Nightmare on Elm
Street without Robert England as Freddy
he is that character yeah and the makeup
they did on the guy in the remake who I
don't even remember who the actor was it
just
didn't it just didn't look good it just
it looked really bad every and
everything was like overly CGI too like
even blood was CGI
and it was just I didn't love it didn't
love it there were some good movies that
came out then I did like scream I liked
all that other kind of stuff but I do
kind of blame scream for bringing back
like a lot of the generic slashers and a
lot of the ironic horror movies which
kind of pissed me off so I didn't love
that either my favorite Korean old
horror movie Miss Le will know what I'm
talking about
pugar
pukari remember that one did we review
pulgasari no I've been wanting to do a
show about the making of that because
that is a crazy [__] story yeah as a
North Korean it's crazy
movie A North
Korean um Kaiju movie yeah giant
monsters yeah his name is
pugio and I thought he was cool looking
the monster was cool looking yeah the
monster look great and it was made by
the same people that directed God Gojira
okay uh and it's because because Kim
Jong-il had him captured he kidnapped he
he kidnapped kidnapped the director the
director's wife who was also another
star and made him made him do it made
them make a Kaiju movie now they
eventually escaped though they
eventually escaped but it's [__]
funny you can't make [__] like that up
can't make it he's like somebody of
James Bond like a James Bond villain
it's [__] insane yeah it's a good
movie though I'm I'm not going to lie it
is a good movie yeah pusar was good it
was is a movie is an anti- capitalist
movie P gasar was a big [__] monster
he started off small but he ate more and
more metal weapons this is happening in
Korea's Medieval Era and the more steel
he ate the bigger he got he was kind of
he was a an allegory
for capitalism unfettered capitalism
yeah just kept growing brain just like
eating everything bigger eating and
getting bigger and bigger it's a good
movie though like I said it's a it's a
and I I really like the at the monster
he's cool looking yeah and the quality
is very high of the little models that
he's destroying and you can watch it for
free on YouTube probably because there's
no copyright on it it's called pulgasari
pulgasari yeah it's North Korean even
though when they say his name in the
film it's always
basio yeah so I think that's the what
what his what his name actually is but
it but they Americanized itess sorry or
anglicized it I guess if you want to say
Zach says dancer in the dark is a great
and super upsetting movie though yeah I
really like dancer in the dark but yeah
I don't know if I'd ever want to watch
it again because holy [__] is that [__]
depressing this Lee doesn't know it she
goes what is that it's a North Korean
movie like monster movie monster movie
called pugio
yeah it's good I mean it's good yeah I
liked it yeah Kim Jong e made it he he
cap he kidnapped
kidnapped a Japanese director and the
director's wife that those directors
heed he wanted to make a big monster mov
he wanted to make a goira movie in North
Korea he thought that was the best way
to go about things you can watch it for
free on YouTube pulgasari
yeah yeah Bryce said Jeepers Creepers
was good yeah I agree like I said
there's not there's movies in the 90s
and early 2000s that came out that were
good but she said she's heard of it but
she didn't see it oh yeah yeah yeah but
I just I don't know I I kind of feel
like there was
especially like the mainstream horror I
just couldn't really get into it
everything was just a remake everything
just seemed really stale you know I
think that was kind of why um Asian
horror got real big like right around
then because people were kind of sick of
whatever was going on like over here
they're just kind of like oh my God we
need to look look to another country you
know what I'm saying so that was why
there was that big thing with all the
Japanese movies and all the remakes of
most of which sucked although I will
argue that the American remake of the
ring is better than the Japanese version
fight
me although I don't think I'm the only
person that says that see he's cool
looking right I think he's cool looking
that's poosari he kind of looks like a
boar a little bit now that script looks
like Japanese that's not Korean but I
don't know who made that poster that
might be a Japanese poster for
yeah
Danny Rowling said Universal Studios
should make a Creature from the Black
Lagoon modernized version like they did
with the mummy Tom Cruz flick which was
good just saying well we're gonna have
to agree to disagree on that because I
did not like the Tom Cruz mummy movie
because it wasn't about the mommy it was
about [__] Tom Cruz wasn't it yeah I
liked it well yeah but I I didn't like
it for that reason
um well I mean if you want to see
something like the Creature from the
Black Lagoon you want to see the Gad Del
Toro movie the shape of water because
that's pretty much like Creature from
the Black Lagoon except he's the good
guy you know what I mean or he's like a
sympathetic character because he's that
he's essentially the Gilman like that
look how cool pugar looks yeah I think
he's cool looking
yeah her yeah he's mad that's capitalism
coming for you yeah Tammy said pulgasari
is on YouTube I thought it was yeah
because you know it's a good movie
it's North Korea so it's like nobody
cares Kore mov what are they going to do
sui it's North Korea's only good movie
and they banned it in North
Korea yeah because once that guy ran
once the director ran and escaped uh Kim
Jong said okay that that pull that movie
erase it like it never
existed he thought he made that's not
how [__] works in the modern world sorry
you can't just like make a whole movie
and then just be like yeah let's just
pretend that didn't happen yeah
yeah somebody put that up on [__]
YouTube somewhere yeah so sorry sorry I
don't know if you know about that but
yeah uh Zach says I think dancer in the
dark Miracle Worker and hereditary made
me cry more than any movie holy crap
yeah Miracle Worker is pretty sad but
they made us watch that in school Danny
said that his uh he's got Godzilla's
face no he's actually got a better face
than Gojira it's more like a bull an
armored steel bull yeah he kind of looks
like that with horns and uh uh he's got
fangs it's it's a better monster than
than Gojira actually it looks a lot
better well the thing about the Godzilla
movies is one there's so many of them
and two like sometimes the monster
looked like badass and sometimes the
monster looked kind of stupid yeah and
then sometimes they had like dumbass
ideas like let's put Mina in there like
this little baby Godzilla and it's just
like look nobody nobody wants to see
that we we want to see a badass Godzilla
stepping on people yeah that's what
everybody wants to see right Lim Lee
agrees she doesn't like Tom Cruz either
I will defend Tom Cruz well he always I
will defend Tom Cruz to the end look I
don't know the man okay I don't but it's
just like I don't like a lot of his mov
I have liked some of his movies he was
good in Interview with the Vampire he
was good in Magnolia yeah he was good in
collateral he's good when he's playing
an [__] yeah when he's trying to play
a good guy I don't buy it no cuz he's
just he's too cocky kind like an [__]
yeah he's too cocky his best movie
Interview with a Vampire he's good in
that he's good yeah and I was skeptical
because when I heard that he was cast in
that much like an rice I was like oh
[__] that noise he was great in in but
he was good in it what was what was one
he was good in Tropic Thunder Cal no not
collateral yeah collateral Cal yeah
where he played like an assassin like an
assassin really good yeah he was good in
that whenever he plays a bad guy yeah or
a dick yeah he's good he's golden yeah
don't try to play a good guy though like
to make me like like you and stuff cuz
I'm not
gonna but he
Tom Cruz does bring it if Tom Cruz makes
a movie I'll give him that he [__]
brings it he gives it 110% he [__]
brings it I I liked all the mission he
us his OT Powers uses OT Powers us to
the best of his Scientology ability
special Scientology special powers he
can if he makes a mistake he reverses
time corrects the the the mistake and
then time goes forward you never know
you never even know
that handy uh talent to have I feel yeah
yeah he's he's looking at it from the
whole track he sees the entire past
present and future he clearly singulari
Superior to all of us Superior OTA ot8
Superior Superman but he I tell you what
he can about he [__] brings it in the
movie his movies usually make a lot of
money his fans come out to see him he
knows what the fans want to see uh most
of the movie that he's made are
extremely high quality I stand I stand
beside or I stand right alongside all
the Mission Impossible movies even the
second one the John Woo one even that
was a cool movie in its day it aged out
yeah I didn't love it it's like it's
it's very dated now but yeah but the new
ones were actually pretty were actually
pretty awesome the newer Mission
Impossibles are right up there with uh
Daniel Craig James Bond I liked him real
good ring Rams is in it Ving RS Ving RS
yeah ring
RS V RS got butt raped in Pulp Fiction
yeah I like him he's a good [__]
character actor though yeah he's great
and uh he's great in Mission
Impossible um everybody in Mission
Impossible does a great job that last
one he's fighting [__] basically
AI Now isn't there like a second part of
that coming out because that was like
two part yeah yeah that because we saw
that in the theater actually it's great
yeah great it was good yeah I put it
right there with I got a soft spot for
[__] Daniel Craig James Bond even the
last one I do too even the last one
which was had was kind of a mixed bag I
still liked some of the homage yeah I
liked I like I like that
movie um yeah some people complained
that he's a little too D and [__]
dark but that's kind of how he was in
the book yeah I don't I don't mind that
in the books he was kind of like that
some people say Well they're putting all
this woke stuff in there yeah but it
didn't get in the way of the the [__]
story it was okay it was just they're
doing they [__] all the [__] B
movies shut the [__] up about this well
here's the thing like I didn't notice
anything that people are just like well
they're saying they're looking for
something to like cry about yeah well
okay the main one that they cried about
us man they're trying to just Pander and
be woke they made Q gay okay he was gay
but wasn't he they they didn't really
specify and I just always kind of
assumed no in the old ones I would say
no he was just an old guy but in the new
ones they they no they he was waiting on
for a date but the thing is though is
that that didn't get in the way of the
movie yeah and all of are bothered by
that kind of thing I'm mystified by
people by that all the James Bond movies
gay people exist get over
it no well they're trying to defend the
property oh well this got to be like
this but they didn't go back and watch
those old
movies from the point of view of the
time in which they were released in the
time in which they were released every
everything in a James Bond movie was
considered to be hip for the time yeah
so all the James Bond movies even back
in the 1960s and the 70s and the 80s you
look at some of these corny 80s bonds
with [__] Roger Moore and [__] some
of that [__] didn't didn't age well but
in those days when it was released it
was kind of hip sure well why do you
think that franchise had surv has
survived for this [__] long because
it changes with the times right so that
they reinterpret the
it's kind of the same character but they
just reinterpret it for the time make
the same [__] movie you made back in
the 60s James doesn't work James Bond
always had contemporary trendy [__] in
it and having a gay character in it
would be is contemporary and trendy so
they're just following what was what I
meaning that's all it was I don't know
all all of that kind of people that
complain about that kind of Shuff I
don't know it just gives me a very it
gives me a very like old man yells at
Cloud but the thing is they're young
guys Y at the clouds they weren't there
they weren't there in the 80s I've told
you before when I say old I don't mean
age I know it's just I mean attitude
right young people can also be old these
guys that are complaining are in their
30s now maybe maybe early 40s they
weren't in the theater with me in 1984
well they don't have watching [__]
perspective watching what James Bond
when it came out you know I mean uh the
the James Bond movie of that year like
uh [__] uh [__] what was there was
one year where I think there were two
James Bond movies in the same year one
was a Timothy Dalton and one of them was
a Roger Moore I think I think I can't
remember because normally they would put
them out like once a year but yeah I
think there was one but I think that's a
more modern yeah I think there was once
where there were
two or or
something might have been a Roger moal
came out or no uh um a Timothy Dalton
came out but then a Roger Moore movie
came out after that and then there was
something about the order but I was in
Brazil when that happened so maybe the
release order was different in Brazil I
don't I don't remember actually how it
happened because they have different
licensing and stuff for different
countries Bryce says in the original
novels James Bond is
bisexual oh really I didn't know that
wouldn't surprise me though so there you
go so quit your [__] crying I mean
none of y'all are crying I'm just saying
um JX Jason said Jenny and Tom I've been
thinking about that big donation you got
on your Richard Simmons video yeah do
you think that was Richard maybe I mean
the screen name was Rachel something
yeah or maybe it was somebody who knew
him yeah and all it said it didn't say
anything it just said thanks on it which
I think is just like the standard
response like when you do a super thanks
but I just thought that was really weird
maybe that was maybe that was the the
maid that his is his
friend may maybe she was just like hey
thanks for not [__] on me yeah we
well we said yeah we we defended her cuz
you don't know that's just a she's
obviously not controlling him with
witchcraft like I said they've been
together for like 30 something years why
would she [__] him over now if she was
going to [__] him over she would have
[__] him over a long time ago I'm sure
I'm sure they're friends she's like oh
I'm playing the long game 30 [__]
years yeah nobody does that
[Laughter]
[Music]
sorry yeah they're talking about um Lim
Lee says Pooky what is she doing um she
was in here a little bit ago was you but
she got like kind of bored I guess I got
to go to the restroom maybe if I see
Pooky I'll break her bring her back
bring can you bring me a drink back
another one okay that's only my first
one what are you talking about okay you
don't have to drive I'm not driving I'm
only going to have one cuz I got to
drive yeah I'm not
drive I'm trying to like uh you know
stock up on drinks right now so I don't
have to get as many at the club they I
mean they don't at the bar they don't
really have a liquor license per se so
they just have kind of those mixed
drinks like in cans you know what I mean
which are very low
alcohol so I kind of try to drink before
we go a lot of people do there's like a
big parking lot and like a lot of people
just bring booze and coolers and their
trunks and like every now and then you
see kind of everybody go outside and
they're like out there drinking and like
smoking pot in their cars and then they
come back in um
but ra Rachel says no I'm not Richard
Simmons so she's here you're here I can
impers I was we were shocked I thought
like Tom like woke me up in the middle
of the night I don't know if it was the
middle of night but it was early and she
was and he was just like I think
somebody just gave us $100 on one and I
was just like no way and I was like look
at Jen's boobs what are you really yeah
yeah yeah okay I'm this is serious now
now you cut my head
off geez this is what I have to deal
with but I'm just teasing I love you Tom
but um but yeah so and the first thing I
thought was that oh my God somebody
messed up like they they meant to put in
like $9.99 and then they're probably
like oh no holy [__] but it's just kind
of like seriously if you did like
seriously that is [__] awesome like
thank you so much I just couldn't
believe it I couldn't believe it because
we were thinking about the one time I
don't know if you guys I mean most of
you guys probably heard of Dan Bell he
did the dead Mall videos in like a b
places and stuff and he was on a live
stream he used to do these live streams
on Saturday nights he might still do
them I'm not sure but like where would
drive around Baltimore for a couple
hours and like talk to everybody and
take him to like abandoned places and
stuff and somebody um gave him a Super
Chat that was
$500 and then he was like holy [__] and
then they were like oh my God I meant to
just give you $5 and then there was like
this whole thing and like Dan Bell F
like so bad and he was just like I don't
know what I'm going to do like I don't
get because you know if you don't do
like super chats and they they kind of
roll all the super chats and add revenue
and all that stuff like in one payment
like through Google AdSense and you only
get it like once a month like it's the
21st at least that's what mine is so
he's just like man I have to like wait
until the 21st and then I can send this
back to this person or whatever but it
was just kind of like it was this whole
[__] drama and that was like what I
thought of that was what I thought of
when I saw it you know what I mean
Rachel said I'm the one who's been
listening for six years you guys have
been the bright spot through a lot of
crap including my stage four cancer
diagnosis oh man man that is like such a
bummer I just like the thing about it is
like we really like doing this show and
especially since we started doing live
streams I really like doing live streams
because I like talking to you guys and
um so I always just kind of think about
it as us like kind of drinking and
[__] around but man every now and
then like one of you guys will say
something like that and I'm like holy
[__] like we are actually like getting
people through some stuff and that's
like pretty cool I don't know like I
feel like I'm not I don't know I feel
like I'm not worthy you know what I mean
but it's like seriously I appreciate
that so much and I hope like how are you
doing now
because what was said that's Rachel she
was the one that gave us that hug she's
here okay she's here so we were talking
about so she's like I'm not Richard
Simmons okay no she just said cuz you
weren't here I'll tell you says I'm the
one who's been listening for six years
you guys have been the bright spot
through a lot of crap including my stage
four cancer diagnosis oh [__] sorry
that's what I'm saying yeah yeah man if
we could help you with that we would I
mean yeah seriously
yeah what did they tell you what what
have they told you m you know how old
are you how much you know what are they
saying what do they say it's going to
happen have they giving you time frame
or cuz you know [__] Kayley our
friend she died of it we watched her
just waste away man well she was super
young too she was young she was 34 yeah
and pretty but it was [__]
heartbreaking
man [__] saw saw videos of her
[__] sucks man saw videos of her in
her final days man she was the size of a
dog maybe 50 PBS [__] his heartbreak
says my cancer has not progress since it
was discovered I say it's because I
can't miss your shows and review that's
where it is okay as long as so we're
well we're just going to keep doing them
then yeah yeah okay we're just gonna
keep doing them then good [__] man I
actually I did two videos yesterday a
movie review and a thing for my crime
Memorial channel so I'm going to put
those up this weekend I felt so
accomplished that I got all that done
yesterday
yeah I couldn't find Pooky Miss Lee I
wonder where she's at I don't know she
probably downstairs play it yeah she's
probably downstairs [__]
around hiding behind the couch or
something like yeah limy said yeah Pooky
should be live too yeah she's like
usually if we're in here for a while
she'll come in and be like what the [__]
are you you guys doing it's like she
gets mad it's like you guys are not like
paying attention to me so you she
constantly paying attention like pay
attention to me this morning I was I was
in bed with Jed we were waking up and of
course I'm coming in behind and my hands
you know I'm a man you know my hands are
going to start going around like this on
her and [__] J I'm sleeping she's
like I'm sleeping why you come here and
I you know trying to pull me like trying
to pull her in trying to pull her in by
her boobs you know and all of a sudden
Pooky gets in between us she's like hey
hey hey hey how about hey hey she's down
by my legs and everything she's trying
to walking in a circle to try to make a
space let me sit here no I ain't got
time for this and she
just got up on her and like put her arms
hands on the side of
my calves and just rusted up against me
like she was playing piano at first then
she and just watching like that Pooky
loves her daddy so much yeah watching
the front door
or watching the door into the bedroom
because she's paranoid the other cat's
going to come she's constantly watching
the door she's looking for Bambi
thinking Bambi will walk in for some
reason I I don't know why she doesn't do
anything when Bambi walks in she just
watches her hey yeah here's the thing
though if if I'm petting
Bambi um and Pooky sees it Pooky will
just sit there and stare yeah and you
can tell like she's got like her little
her her pupils are really small she sits
there
yeah yeah and why aren't you petting me
why you yeah yeah they play together
though like they don't hate each other
like they don't fight or anything they
chase each other around and they play
and stuff but man so and now I'm like
really so like it's like navigating a
Minefield because it's like well I got a
pet Bambi because Bambi is like super
affectionate she's just like B pet me
yay and so it's like if I do that I'm
like where's Pooky I don't want her to
see this because she'll get like all
upset cuz she's just kind of like and
then if you go like after you're done
petting Bambi like if you go over and
try to pet Pooky she'll be like yeah and
she'll walk off she won't lay and pet
her she's like nope yeah you're petting
that other Kitty so yeah your hands are
dirty yeah you touching you're tainted
yeah it's just it's hilarious those two
you got her stink all over you dirty
yeah Rachel said it was breast cancer uh
that metastasized to my bones Jenny and
I are only a month apart in age
so she's same age as me man it makes us
paranoid yeah anything happen at any
time I mean I try to think about it yeah
that's why see you got to appreciate you
got to appreciate this [__] right here
yeah well I got to appreciate this [__]
also yeah I do though I do Chances with
me how I live I would die by
misadventure I'd wreck a motorcycle get
hit by a car or shoot me yeah or you
would like start a fight and like get
shot or something yeah that's I yeah
fight and then I get shot
yeah that's why I always kind of worried
about we were talking about this earlier
when we were at the um at the Chinese
restaurant cuz he was saying um oh I
could give you like this much more what
was it testosterone or whatever it is
that you're nandrolone the nandrolone
that you're giving me yeah I'd probably
put a little bit of test in it too
though yeah and he's just like oh I
should give you like this much more but
it's like yeah but you would probably
like turn into a dude and it's like that
would be like a really bad influence
because now like if Tom goes somewhere
like I'm going to tear this
[__] up like let let's not she
already kind of encourages me sometimes
that's what I mean and it's just like
well and the drunker I get I just be
like yeah let's [__] this dude up you
know what I mean so it's like I'm
already kind of like that so I don't
need I don't need more of that because
like we're both going to jail yeah you
know what I mean cuz it's like if you
come out and just be like let's [__]
kill this dud I'm like yeah you know
what I mean I'm like yeah we we don't
need we don't need to go there beat him
get him get him get in there like she's
already kind of done that you know what
I mean some dude grab her ass and go wa
you and she's like yeah yeah get him
get you have that comment in seriously
yeah and honestly like when we were at
mannequins the other day and those like
[__] douchy guys were like getting my
[__] nerves I was just kind of like
cuz I was kind of inebriated so I was
just kind of like I I think I'm might
[__] these dudes up yeah
she those dudes would have run through
you though you just mad well I was just
mad but just mad well I mean they were
kind of dumpy
yeah but even on even an average SI even
an average man can okay we'll look at it
this
way Green River Killer what was that
name [__] asshole's name um oh yeah
yeah yeah uh name oh [__] it just went
it was in my head and then it just went
the Green River Killer yeah yeah I know
what you're talking about Gary Ridgeway
Gary Ridgeway yeah see I knew it was in
there man I look at Gary Ridgeway man
and he's just a [__] nothing a zero
all right I'd run through five Gary
ridgeways without any [__] effort all
right he was just a weak
man it's amazing that that weak man
killed dozens and dozens of women with
his bare hands yeah you know so there is
a big difference in upper body strength
yeah yeah I know that even with a weak
man for instance
you're bench pressing 40 lbs and getting
a decent
workout to to me to get a decent lift
has to be like 250 lbs right my maximum
lift is like
330 330 PBS it's my maximum one rep one
rep max probably that's the last I
checked and that was [__] seven eight
months ago cuz you don't really at my
age you don't want to do one rep Maxes
you could hurt yourself
in the recovery time you miss other tr
you miss training it's better to just go
with something lighter do multiple
repetitions of it you'll get more out of
it but every now and then I'll try to go
every six months seven months I'll go in
there and test see what my one rep max
is and that last one was probably about
three probably about 330 I think and I
could have done more but not much
more but that was good enough I didn't
want to find out what total Max was like
you hurt yourself or you're running well
yeah you might like [__] then I'd
have to run in there and You' be like I
can't move yeah like I'm a [__]
arms I broke my body Bryce says she's a
good little girl what a good little girl
Pooky is so cute how she gets jealous
yeah she's um she adjusted cuz she sees
that it's not different like she still
gets up on the bed and she still gets
meat sticks she still gets the same
routine but it's still she's always like
what's that other Kitty doing are you
petting petting that other Kitty I don't
like it yeah Lim Lee said the same thing
I also have two cats have to pet at the
same time yeah but the two cats will not
let me pet them at the same time if you
try to do that they're just like nope
they both leave like well Bambi doesn't
care she's just kind of like yeah
whatever pet me Po's like I'm not being
involved in this situation yeah she's
like I'm going over here I I she's
always just kind of like I'm only going
to allow it if you're giving all of your
attention to me yeah well because which
is understandable because I mean we
raised Pooky from like that big from
like she was Tiny a tiny kitten she
lived in the bed with us yeah a little
bitty kitten so she thinks she's a tiny
person she thinks she's our daughter
yeah basically she thinks she's a baby
so when this other cat came in when we
got Bambi she was not a kitten she was
18 months old and she'd already had a
litter they told us um so Pooky was just
kind of like what the [__] is going on
with this who is this Kitty I mean and
we got got her because we thought Pooky
needed a buddy you know we didn't want
Pooky to get Bard P had two had two
adult cats when she was a baby living
with her one of them died yeah and then
uh the other one beigeing she's still
alive yeah be doesn't play with her we
had a cat named Garbo a long time ago
but he died he was super old yeah that
was years ago yeah like Pooky used to
jump on him when he was a kitty she to
beat him like she was a ride at
Disneyland he seemed to like it though
he seemed to like having cat another C
jump on brce says she is your daughter
yeah we do kind of think of her like
that we do kind of think of that she's
in your face constantly if if I start
working on something she tries to help
me yeah I'm
putting what are we doing what you she
helps you put the laundry away yeah I'm
doing leather work sometimes you know
trying to make the part of the Bane
costume and she's putting her face in
there she's grabbing rivets with her
mouth and carrying in places bring the
rivet back you know I'm trying to stick
an owl through the [__]
leather and I'm like don't poach
yourself and she's trying to smell the
end of a Sharp object said don't do it
and she's looking like what why not yeah
she has to be in the middle of
everything and seriously every day when
you make the bed she jumps up on the bed
it tries to help you make bed and tries
to help you make the bed by running on
it or going underneath she thinks she's
helping yeah she's she's I I do tell her
it's like you're such a good helper
she's not helping at all she's she's now
she get on top when you're making the
bed she's get on top and run to every
corner make sure it's knocking it down
sh knocking it down she got to make sure
she's supervising she's make sure it's
like correct
yeah and we've I think we have videos of
her like when you put when you dump like
laundry on the bed she just like
immediately goes and and like runs
underneath the pile and then sits there
and then if when you start taking
laundry away she gets upset like no no
no Bry said that he thought the Green
River Gary Ridgeway was a guy who just
would kill women because kill hookers
because he didn't want to pay uh no no
he wasn't cuz he was also a necropile he
was going back while they were very
rotten and having sex with him and
that's just not some dude that didn't
want to pay no so that's [__] he was
a maniac issues the cops were doing he
would go he says yeah I kept going back
you know the same one and they were like
and they're doing the the the cops are
looking at the dates that he's given the
amount of time and it was like in the
middle of summer and she like we talking
about man she'd been out there for like
3 weeks and 90° weather that's [__]
Rotten real
rotten and and and he and he'd like yeah
yeah she was pretty bad and they were
like but why but why and he goes but why
and he goes well it was free was there
but no that's not what what it was he
was into nasty look so is your hand and
some lotion that is also kind of free he
was into how disgusting it
was had to have been dude was [__]
weird that's weird why didn't you just
get a sex doll actually I asked that
about a lot of serial killers it's like
why don't you get a sex doll or if you
if you don't have that much money
because they are kind of expensive I
admit but CU we've been looking into
getting
one you're way but I know but um why
don't you get one of the kind of like
Pocket [__] things that's not what he
was doing that's not what his thing
was he wanted Dead rotten women that's
what he wanted so the sex doll wouldn't
get he wanted that to be a real person
he wanted it to be decomposed over time
he was obviously had some and he had
some
kind
yeah he said that he sometimes
afterwards he had his all his clothes
off he was doing that well because it
stank he didn't want to ruin his clothes
and then he would go into the water to
wash off because it was all it was
always by the the edge of the river
and he'd wash off and he come back put
his clothes on from from what I remember
yeah I know he said he washed
off so he so he knew it stank but he
liked that that's a weird [__] yeah
people because at three weeks man
there'd be all kinds
of decomposition maggots this is the S
this it was hot the summer decomposition
maggots you'd have a lot of water and
fluid leaking out of the
body it had been black greasy oh [__]
[__] nasty can't imagine
nasty eyes probably would have been
sockets
flies so you're talking about a dude
who's [__] nuts man yeah I mean
[__] crazy that is it's not normal
sexual attraction well obviously you
know that's opposite that's the
opposite Tom's getting gross out yeah
that's gross I'm still remembering the
show that we did about the necrophiles
and you like walked out at the end
because you couldn't take it
I still get messages about that show
yeah be like walking out at then and I
just thought that was really funny
because I think it's gross too but it's
just kind of like I kind of get amused
by um how gross down he gets by things
yeah like that kind of amuses me I get
grossed out too but not as much as he
does I've been around things that have
been dead for a long time yeah animals
and dead you know been out in the wood
it is nasty and you see a dog that's
just [__] been you know killed hit by
a train you know
kid
behind and they would just beo and
filled with [__] maggots fly Lara
just spilling out and the smell as your
little kid you'd be gagging and can you
imagine like I could imagine something
putting your dick in that oh man what
the
[__] God Tom just lost his bone be like
the dog itd be there and there'd be a
wet spot around it yeah you know what I
mean [__] with all the fluids
separating and [__] and the [__]
yeah we'd have some Brave kid with us
he'd get a big old long Pole or a stick
and try to turn it over there's always
one cuz there's always one guy watch
this watch this turn it over poke trying
to turn it over you know what I mean
[__] FES and [__] one kid that would
do that yeah you know we're little boys
you still [__] gagging and throwing
up you know but looking you know just so
maybe he maybe he did that as a little
kid and somehow it made a connection I
don't know cuz little boys in America
will do that
run around with a pack of dogs little
girls will do that too like you know
especially if they're in a group like
other Bo a bunch of boys yeah cuz I had
Brothers yeah so it's like that's kind
of a similar thing yeah you're grossed
out but it's like you're still kind of
fascinated you got to turn it over turn
it over and I think that's a pretty
Universal like when you're a kid yeah
but you know it's gross yeah but you're
still kind of like FAS cuz kids are
fascinated by gross [__] but like you
usually grow out of that yeah you're but
some people do do not I
guess they just kind of stay in
that phas my curiosity got Satisfied by
the time I was probably about eight the
day we found the buckets we found the
buckets okay did you ever tell me this
story I don't know I don't remember the
bucket story The yeah we found his okay
oh maybe you did okay you got to tell me
again though I don't remember this was
behind Dominguez Elementary School oh I
remember okay you did tell me this there
was a [__] railroad track there that
railroad track this is in California
there's a railroad track would go to the
wildlife
preserve and The wildli Preserve was
near all those damn LA River drainage
things you see in the movie The Big
concrete rivers with the little river in
the middle these are where they filmed
Greece where they did the the the the
car race gree where in the 1950s they
fought the giant ants in the movie Them
y so that was down iconic yeah or in
Terminator 2 where the Terminators jumps
the motorcycle and they're doing the
truck chase down in there and wreck the
truck that's all in the flood control
system is what it's called but that
would go to the wildlife preserve well
we were down the wildlife preserve and
on the way back we were going up to
railroad tracks railroad tracks is where
we would find dead dogs and [__] but
they weren't there all the time but when
we did find one oh we got another one
you know I don't know how at least you
never found a person like in [__] no
we were afraid of fck find this is this
is how children think we were afraid of
finding bums but we never did we thought
we were going to find some homeless boms
right we're on our way and
uh we were behind our school going
behind Dominguez Elementary School
following the railroad tracks and in the
direction we were going off the left on
the right was the school on the left was
a big empty field the field used to be
Strawberry Fields
Japanese Farmers from Japan lived in
this area at one time Japanese are from
Japan yeah but they weren't Americans
though some of them were Americans I got
a story about that Chris toy was the was
a friend of mine I grew up with her her
dad was Japanese Cowboy he had he had a
stable with horses in it in this area
within walking distance of where I'm
talking about and he married American
blonde chick and Christina was born and
she was what you call haa she was half
Japanese and half
Caucasian she was pretty she won this
big beauty pageant at my Military
Academy because they were asking around
all the school who who knows any girl
that wants to go to beauty pageant and
[__] I thought of Christina so I
volunteered her and she wanted to go so
she's in my yearbook if I could find it
Christina's in
there she she won matter of fact anyway
near where her dad's Stables were okay
now this this um strawberry field ex
Japanese strawberry field got purchased
by a development company and they were
going to put
in like Warehouse type stuff in there or
uh in that area so you could walk
through it because it was under
development that development ended up
being where Jesse James uh motorcycle
Chopper shop ended up being in there now
you know how what do they called yeah
that wasn't West Coast Choppers was it
what the [__] was the name of that yeah
yeah yeah and it was in that that's
where his Chopper shop was going to be
you they had a whole television program
there well they were just starting to
pave that area with roads going through
it a bunch of them like access roads to
wear these little Warehouse things
little garages you'd be able to
rent and we saw on one of those roads a
big [__] stack of those five gallon
buckets you know those five gallon
buckets for like food service they had
the lids on
it there must have been 20 of them in a
big old [__] po uh stacked up on the
end of one of those
roads so we're like look at those
buckets what what is that so of course
you know there's five of us let's go
look let's go look I'd be like nothing
good is going to come with that so we're
looking at the buckets and um Mike was
with us Mike was a little bit older than
us I think he might have been nine maybe
10 and he grabs a bucket off it and it's
sosing he's going it's got something L
got some kind of water in so we're
trying to figure out how to take the lid
off and I don't remember how we did it
we're pulling and pulling and pulling it
was It was kind of sealed you know you
got to pry them off what's that you got
to pry them off I think yeah we I think
we ended up prying it
off and uh we were working on it and all
of a sudden the lid came loose and the
[__] went fly the [__] [__] turned
over over and inside of it was a plastic
bag and a [__] smell hit me like
crazy and as it was turning over the
plastic bag kind of [__] opened and
this [__] white sludge came out and I
started [__] and it got on me and I was
[__] gagging and gagging and throwing
up it stank it was the worst smell I'd
ever [__]
smelled and I could hear her B go oh oh
oh oh what have we done yeah oh and I
heard and I heard Jimmy Jimmy North he
he ended up being a a chip a California
Highway Patrol they had a whole you know
chips he one of those when you got
older which is a special kind of it was
kind of a California Elite policeman all
the girls liked him you had to be
good-looking back in the day to be a
chips like P and John yeah they were
like sex from the TV show yeah kind of
like California State Highway Patrol
guys they roll around a motorcycles and
cars this is this is Jimmy was about
eight and and he's going it's fish
[__] and I was and what it was it was
buckets and buckets of fish heads and
fish guts where somebody somewhere had
dressed a whole bunch of fish and just
gotten them meat out right and they were
throwing away all the heads somewhere
they illegally dumped it there just left
it and I got some of that [__] on me and
man I was gagging all [__] day and
came home my mother's like what is that
[__] smell yeah that smell is
probably like up in your nose like can't
get rid of it rotten liquified fish
smell like that you can't yeah and
[__] I think she had to throw those
pants away yeah I was probably wearing
tough skins remember them tough skins I
remember those from [__] Sears yeah
from Sears yeah they were like jeans my
brother had those yeah they like jeans
with [__] knee pads the knees were so
[__] reinforced on those things it
was like wooden
boards yeah and they were like red Red
Jeans red and green and [__] I remember
those yeah it's probably what it was
I didn't have any I don't think but my
brother my brother like stiff as [__]
those [__]
pants so well because moms were probably
like sick of like having to buy jeans
and like your your children would like
run around and wear them out and [__]
and they tear them and like [__] them up
and [__] like that they're like here
just wear these cuz you were on your
knees playing a [__] yeah yeah
they're tired of spending money tired of
spending money on your ass right exactly
so
yeah so after that that was the end of
dead stuff it was that was a
traumatizing [__] experience I can
see that I I avoided anything that was
dead yeah you're like yep I've learned
my lesson I've learned my lesson rotten
fish well like I said I I kind of feel
like the reason that humans have a
response like that to that smell is
because nature says tox stay away from
that yeah it's very toxic so the fact
that you're just kind of like hey let's
look I'm just like yeah yeah let's not
yeah let's
not you know yeah it was and it was like
the summertime in California so all
those fish guts had been in in the
sealed up in those plastic I imagine
containers probably for I can imagine
weeks and then they dumped them off
there in the middle of the night cuz
they couldn't figure out where to get
rid of them and we stumbled upon them
they were it had been weeks old it was
just [__] although you didn't even
look like fish until the other guys were
kind of like looking at that soup and
you could see like the cartilage heads
you know those the heads and they were
like clear I remember them looking clear
like clear cartilage looking heads there
weren't even any eyes in it fish it was
just like white it was like white
soup that's how rotten it was well um in
the bucket's defense you guys did not
have to open them no so that's on you no
just saying well kids got to know in
that bucket I really didn't have to know
I'm just like you know what it's
probably going to be something bad so
I'm just going like leave it Danny
Rowling said uh talking about uh Gary
Ridgeway his wife wouldn't put out as
much as he'd like I guess that's what he
said and he said he was a nfo yeah and
then also Danny Rowling said in Japan
wives are okay with the husband seeing
hookers are they I I kind of feel like
maybe they aren't all but maybe I don't
know maybe that's a cultural thing yeah
well it's uh my understanding is that
those guys go to those Hostess clubs
they work these long hours
and probably at that time the
relationship's probably kind of broken
down she never sees that dude anyway so
I think they're kind of yeah I mean I
could see that I don't think
they're I will and they kind of get
resentful of that dude and he's just
he's more like a roommate
now and evidently this is maybe old
school I remember from the studies this
is at least in the 90s or so that those
dudes had no home skills they couldn't
even cook they didn't do any they didn't
have any they couldn't clean they
couldn't help in the apartment or the
house really all they did were they were
just office guys you know so the when
those dudes retired those women tried to
get rid of them because all all they did
was just sit around in the apartment
they didn't get anything done like you
guys are just like in my way usess yeah
they were just useless once they once
they were retired you're just messing
stuff up that I have to clean up after
you now it wasn't just the wasn't from
the data that I remember reading and
this might still be going on
today it wasn't just that the dudes were
hanging out with the was
uh they weren't hookers in the way that
you would think it in America they were
kind of like what up in Korea when I was
up there I wouldn't really they're like
more like Hostess clubs that was kind of
that's where I was going it was more
kind of like a Hostess the Korean
version of a hostess club it's like a
nightclub with a bunch of Apartments out
in the back and those girls would grab
you and take you to that damn apartment
and take your money take your money but
yeah you were happy happy though you're
like all right I got picked she picked
me yeah he was telling me about that I
think you talked about that a little bit
on the show but like you told me about
it they were in high demand you know
what I mean we outnumbered them a lot
just because you went in there didn't
mean anything had happened for you you
know uh now there were other places
where it was like a sure thing it was
more like a broel you know but um my
understanding is is not only those dudes
doing that like hostess club stuff that
the wives are are having
Affairs well I would cuz they don't see
the dude cuz they're just like where is
yeah and there's evidently kind of some
resentment well he's off with these
hostesses right and when he's not
working he's not here he's out with his
hostesses right so I'm going to go I'm
go [__] this dude right well you Fu Mr
whatever you can't blame him yeah you
know hey go down to raponi and [__]
[__] some foreign
guy that's the thing yeah and do I don't
know like we were talking about about
this because you were talking about the
um cuz you know when we did the show
about um Y young CH the Korean serial
killer so we talked a lot about Korea
and we were kind of talking about a
little bit after the show too and
because you know Tom was in the Army and
he was stationed in Korea for a while
and you know yeah and when he was
younger he was much younger and single
and he just kind of like you know
availed himself of the services
available let's call it that everybody
else was right so like that's what
everyone was doing part of the culture
so we were talking about it so I was
just kind of like I don't know like like
I said
obviously there's a spectrum I kind of
feel like it would
be like ju okay from my point of view it
would be less
upsetting if your spouse or whatever
[__] around with a hooker rather than
like a person that they knew you know
what I mean there's no relationship
right but it's still I'd still be upset
yeah but I'd be slightly less upset if
it was I'd still be upset I'm not saying
that but I'd be slightly less upset yeah
but I would still be upset in the sense
that I'm like yeah no you know what I
mean but it's not exactly the same
you're not supposed to be you're not
supposed to be doing [__] behind your
wife's back I mean yeah really I mean
that you really shouldn't be doing it
behind your girlfriend's back but even
your wife's back you don't that's why
and that seems kind of easy but I guess
like a lot of people like don't really
well some dudes are married and they get
sick of the girlfriend but they they get
sick of the wife get it but if you do
then just say that like I said I kind of
feel like the whole problem is that look
if you are with somebody and you're like
hey I'm not really feeling it anymore so
just break up with that person like
don't like go around behind their back
and do [__] that's fck listen what Miss
Lee says don't get caught by your wife
go you go to the place yeah right you
don't yeah well okay when I was there
all the guys that would go with me we
were all single and we were all in our
20s early to mid
20s which is about the same age as the
as the women that worked in there right
and now some of them were older but
still cute and they had them in there
some of in their 40s ran into one of
like 40 something but you really
couldn't tell they just you know she
looked like she was still 20s
something didn't matter she was cool too
I only went Tom hit it anyway
yeah yeah that was suck in what 21 21
single
man yeah 21 and single and coming off
with the DMZ was just hard work and
Military [__] 247 for a [__] the
whole month you get one day off yeah so
yeah you're you're going to cut loose I
get it yeah I get it you need some
female companion [__] man even if it's
only for just a little [__] few
minutes yeah well it's just you know you
put some of that female Magic on
you is that what we have it's magic man
yeah oh yeah it becomes precious when
you're not getting it you're in an all
male [__] you're in an all male
situation 247 girls are magic oh it's
magic that's why I talk about it so much
that's why I do what I do I value
it you do to be I value it yeah you do
to be no I I think women are great yeah
now not all of them but the good you
know good ones are Tom actually does
like to hang out with me yeah God knows
why I like yeah I
like was my best friend for [__] 13
years yeah you
know I Haven been married to her for a
few months but we were married anyway I
mean we acted like we were married
pretty much all that time yeah we've
been together a long time long time no I
liked women just and you know all of
them had kind of like something to offer
if they were within the age range that
was you know you know you know that
appealed to
be you know some of them might just have
a terrible personality but she looks
great you you leav give her credit she
looks good though she looks good yeah
she's a [__] man I can't stand that bit
she's got a [__] beautiful ass she
knows it too might hit it one time yeah
I would I would hit it but I don't want
her to know that I'm hitting I'm going
to hit it spiritually I don't like it I
don't really like her but she's got a
[__] great ass you know that's just
the way the mans think every man in
there knows I'm talking
about yeah well like I said you don't
want a woman you don't like to have any
kind of power with you so you got to
keep that element to yourself like I
can't [__] stand you man you're
[__] [__] you got a great ass though
but you just think that
yourself don't tell her that because
then it's going to be she think she's
got power it's going to Whole yeah it's
going to be a whole thing I get it some
women just have great personalities and
they're you know they're not gorgeous
but they got a they got a cute figure
you know what I mean and and they're
they're enough men men are very that's
the one thing that makes men different
than women men are very very um
open-minded when it comes to you know
what I mean um they'll accept a woman
that they like she doesn't have to be
the top woman she they just have to like
well women will do that too yeah kind of
women will do that too but you have to
meet their criteria sure but like
everyone's different like I said
everyone's got different man kind of
don't really have much of a criteria
though like she doesn't really have to
have any money you know she doesn't
really have to have much
status she just has to be cute you have
to like her yeah you know to have a good
time with her that's you know and uh
well now chicks will do that too they'll
just like hit like poor ass dudes that
are like that look good that's kind of
temporary though but yeah they're not
going to hang around with that dude
because they're's like oh my God this
dude's GNA like [__] drain me dry
yeah a dude will take a guy a girl who's
poor and not all that goodl looking but
he likes her he'll take her and fix her
up and take care of her you know because
he feels like he's needed it's like a
pig malen situation yeah now she's
gorgeous and [__] six feet tall and
makes a [__] ton of money and stuff guys
aren't even going to try with that
they're like ah what would she want with
me that's why those girls have such a
hard time she need she didn't need your
ass that's why y like the in the male
escort game there's a misconception that
those dudes have sex with old women they
have some escorts they just deal with
men but there are other male escorts
that are Elite male
escorts almost all of almost always
they're jacked and they look kind of Mo
model looking
guys and
um they only work with women but what's
funny is that it's always young women
that that that hire them young women
that are professionals that make a lot
of
money they can't get dates because the
men of their level are going out with
the girl from Starbucks the cute girl at
Starbucks they don't want a rich
woman because why they have so many
offers from really cute poor girls to
choose from that they have more fun with
those um so a lot of successful this is
also holds true in Japan they have host
clubs they got some player ass Japanese
guys you know look like something from a
K-pop band and those girls in there
spending big money on those guys and
there some of my business owners make a
[__] ton of money and they're just they
they make so much money that they're out
of the dating Market Japanese guys don't
want
them
um and another thing that Elite male
escorts not only Rich professional girls
it's other female prostitutes they'll
hire a male
prostitute on a day off you would think
that well [__] don't they get sick
[__] all these dudes no if you listen
to
interviews like Al is a good one that
does a lot of good she does a lot of
good interviews she says the sex with
those dudes is vanilla is [__] and real
boring they're nice guys but they're
older guys that she chicks through she
doesn't really have much in common with
them and it's not for her it's not real
satisfying sex it's just a
job well a lot of those es female
escorts of that level they have
money they can't have boyfriends a lot
of them or the or they lost their
boyfriend or husband because of the
business
so on a day off they'll hire an escort
yeah I get it I don't think I would ever
do that but but you you're not a hooker
I get it you're not a hooker yeah I know
you're not Lonely no I'm not so they're
Lon but I mean even if I was I don't
think I'd ever get that
lonely yeah well another thing is is
that you're also you're also in your 50s
you're mature and welldeveloped the
escorts that are hiring these these guys
are in their 20s yeah 20s and 30s they
kind of feel like oh my God I have to
have a boyfriend I don't have a
relationship and shouldn't that I'm kind
of past that stage and a lot of times
they have a relationship with an elite
male escort who's a regular with them
like they have just that one because he
listens to all her problems and he's
friends with her
and he's got a couple female escorts he
doesn't talk to her about that though
you know what I mean but he's got he
might be seeing a couple of them on a
regular
basis and so she's getting his hooker
money that funny at like $1,500 a day
hey you can spend your money however you
want Bryce says totally off topic but
I'm gonna say it James makoy is hot I
agree especially as the Beast villain in
split the guy that was in Split like oh
yeah yeah yeah that was a great I was
always kind of like into James yeah he's
he's actually like there's something
kind of sexy about him yeah everybody's
agree say hell yeah girls are magic also
yeah brace also said wives need to know
and consent to it otherwise it's scummy
talking about uh going to hookers and
stuff yeah it's different like I said
it's different if everybody knows what's
involved like I said as long as no one
is doing anything behind anyone's back
yeah it's a big deal then I don't have a
problem with it like if you you if you
are in an open relationship with your
spouse or whatever and it's just like
yeah you can go [__] whoever you want
and you can [__] whoever you want and
like you know that it's going on then
that's fine there's nothing wrong with
that at all we know people that do that
yeah and we know people that do that and
like I said I that it doesn't bother me
I'm not upset about it or nothing like
that the only problem I have is
deception I don't like deception um you
know that's all and I think like most
people are probably same you know I know
one married couple
where it's out of control I
mean they do things with other couples
single people and then the guy leaves
with the woman and does [__] for [__]
sometimes you know all night and leaves
his wife at home I would never do that
in a situation like that but cuz since
she's like left out you know what I mean
so that that's I don't think that's very
cool uh then I know another um but she
doesn't seem to care here a that's what
I mean if that's what they're cuz you
know I know who you're talking about
yeah you know I'm talking about um but
if that's what they the agreement
they've come to then okay and then
another like I wouldn't do that but
other people are not me so another
couple I know is they've been together a
long time about 15
years and the wife she's hot you know
who who this
is
she has relationships with girls and
women and he knows but he's not involved
in it and they'll go on trips they'll go
to [__] Japan together the two girls
and he just stays at home yeah yeah
they're they're out doing their things
he doesn't really mind yeah oh she
deserves it she's been a good wife that
kind of yeah yeah yeah like I said as
long as everyone's on the same page now
evidently then whatever I don't I'm not
bother
evidently guys aren't allowed that's not
on the menu evidently but she doesn't
care if but see that's the thing and I
think that in a lot of ways some couples
that are kind of like polyamorous or
something like that like like I said I'm
not hugely into that like I said it's
all kind of like situational I guess
yeah cuz you know we might get into that
because we have gotten into that you
know just
situationally but it's kind of like I I
sort of feel like
if you're going to do that in some ways
it's better because you have to be like
super open with communication and maybe
you have to be like more open with
communication than a normal quote
unquote couple would be if you're not
doing that because I kind of feel like
the normal thing is to hey I'm kind of
sick of my wife but I'm not going to
tell her that I'm just going to go have
an affair yeah without telling her but
it's like if you had just like opened up
to her and said hey I'm kind of not
feeling this or whatever it's like she
might have been like oh let's bring it a
third person or let's or you can go well
you know what I mean and I'm I'm just
saying that those are normies most of
them people well yeah that's what I'm
saying we come from a a subculture the
god subculture is a lot it's a lot more
open more that sexually I feel like and
a lot of times this is happening between
married couples in the scene or it's a
married couple with a girl that they
know from the scene
or so because they're in this club scene
and the subculture together it's not
like this is happening in some with an
outsider so it's not like a random like
everybody knows this person like oh yeah
yeah she's famous you know what I mean
it's that kind of [__] we know that girl
oh yeah yeah so it's very different it's
kind of like the same thing that
probably like in the in back in the old
days rock stars lived that way actors
and actresses lived like that they all
knew each
other so they did weird [__] yeah but
like I said I'm much more an advocate of
even if it's [__] that I wouldn't
personally do um if people if everyone's
on the same page everyone knows what's
going on nobody is being lied to or
[__] over then whatever and in in in
our subculture there's a lot less need
to
lie because the people are well
everyone's going to find out yeah you
can't really lie but the people are a
little sc's not that big every Everybody
tends to be friends so somebody's going
to find out about your [__] yeah and
eventually everyone's gonna know so but
you know another thing is is just the
the sexual orientation of the scene is
more is very alternative well everyone's
just kind of like whatever yeah they're
not as I kind of feel like that's the
sexual orientation of the god scene is
whatever when it used to be back in the
90s the sexual orientation was BDSM that
well there's a lot of that still yeah
but I'm just kind of like now like
nobody worries about it they're just
kind of like hey I like like you you
like me it doesn't matter like what it's
not hippie though it's more like fetish
yeah uh it still is kind of fetish you
know uh threesom and weird things
between couples there's a fetish element
to it or flavor to it it's not really
like a hippie
flavor uh well sometimes it
is yeah there's some of that too some of
that but cuz so it's not really like
free love per se there's a lot of rules
and [__] and it's mind games but they're
into that
yeah because I mean free love is yeah
great like as an idea but I don't stand
it doesn't work out in
practice um you know what I mean but the
but the nice thing about the scene that
we're in is that everybody knows
everybody or knows somebody that knows
that person and everything's to Choice
really and nobody's really pigeon hold
so you're not expected to do anything
you do whatever you want yeah you can do
whatever you want yeah like me and Jen
basically we're very traditional in
general
comparatively compared to them other
people we're traditional yeah like we've
done threesim and [__] but it's just
like nothing like some of the other
people and like nobody like thinks of it
as a big deal nobody like is all upset
about it everybody just her yeah yeah
yeah yeah her yeah you know that's all
it is but the thing is though and
another thing that's kind of good about
it is that if somebody does something
[__] up everybody knows about it like
immediately because that [__] will get
around in seconds look what Miss Le says
wait a minute well Bryce said a long
time ago yeah what do you guys think of
of guys that care about a girl's body
count there's something to be said for
it it depends
on he's talking about how many women
don't know if you guys don't know what
he's talking about some guys fixate a
lot on how many yeah men it's a little
bit of a double standard I would
argue well it depends it depends on
who's asking this that's true okay
uh it also depends on what kind of
relationship are you looking for with
this girl you trying to marry her or you
just want to date her or you just want
to sleep with her if you just want to
sleep with her dater then the body count
shouldn't ma shouldn't matter if you're
going to marry her it might if it's an
extreme
number uh because there's a tendency to
where if a woman has gone through a lot
of guys from an early age she has a
problem connecting with dudes it's all
especially if she's kind of I think
that's true of dudes as well like I
think women also like look a scance at
dudes that have a really high chances
are for the reason cuz he's going to
keep doing what he's doing well yeah
that too like one he can't commit or
he's just going to keep banging random
chicks and I can't trust him or
something so it's kind of the same both
ways so in some ways that that um is
kind of the same thing with women now
there's always exceptions to it like
what happens
if you run into some girl you like her
turns out she got forced into
prostitution or something okay that's
going to be extremely high body count
but she was forced into but that's not
her fault not really first so what do
you do with a situation like that that
might be a good woman yeah I wouldn't be
bothered by that like I said if anything
you were forc might mentally messed up
you don't know it's it's well she
probably is prob it's on a it's going to
be on a Case by case basis um but a
woman with a low body count could have a
lot of problems too what if she's only
been with a couple guys but then she got
Gan raped or something like that by
three or four violently she's going to
carry a lot of baggage for a while
before she can get over that so it's
going to depend then you're going to
like well I don't should I get in a
relationship with this I don't know you
know what I mean because uh everyone's
situation is different is what right
right right so I don't know like I mean
your body count if you want to call it
that is significantly higher than mine
yeah than mine yeah uh mine I feel like
is probably I mean it's not probably
it's definitely below average Jen was
married a lot during I was married a
long a long time I got married in my
early 20s yeah and I was married for 14
years yeah and I didn't cheat on him
right so I really so I really only
racked up a body count like after the
divorce yeah you know what I mean and I
was there for it I was with right so it
wasn't that many people it wasn't that
many people like it was some but it
wasn't that many yeah I knew who the
dudes were so I was worried about it
they were all good guys he knew them
they were good guys except for one yeah
except for one yeah I you and I saw you
kick him to the curb like yeah [__] you
get out of here they never saw that dud
it again right yeah um so uh so so I
never really gave a [__] about Jen's
body count no but like I said it's
pretty low no mine's pretty low yeah I
knew it was but it still wouldn't have
mattered she she could had three times
that and it still would have been fine
with me it just cannot be unusually high
that's the problem because the thing
about it is like or unusually bad like
my age yeah um it wouldn't be weird if
it was three times as high as it
wouldn't it wouldn't right because it's
like over the years like yeah [__]
happens you know what I mean like that's
another thing well and that's what and
that's why I'm not bothered by yours
because like you were single almost all
of that time like you were married what
2 years 3 years something like that but
other than that you were say like you
had girlfriends here and there but it's
just kind of like most of that time you
were single so it's like yeah obviously
yeah I wasn't cheating on anybody I
wasn't breaking any rules I was just
that's what I mean yeah that's what I
mean so it's like that's why I didn't
think it was like all that strange we're
going have to leave in a bit in time
yeah I know but uh what I was going to
say is uh about count once
a body count really only matters to when
you're dealing with young women and a
young guy and he's trying to get married
kind of early that might
matter outside that situation is not as
critical doesn't really matter body
count doesn't matter to a 40 50 40 plus
guy yeah because your expectations are
not the same right you know and maybe
you've already been married and had kids
you're not looking for another family so
you're not looking for the same kind of
woman right that the the St you know
your expectations are not the same you
might be just looking for a companion
that's fun and and you can trust her
well you might go trust you probably
trust a woman like that yeah you know
doesn't
if she if she's all about you look man
[__] we got I know a guy in the porn
industry you know Amy uh what's her name
Amy Quinn Amy Quinn's her her porn name
I know her husband she does all kinds of
wild [__] on film she's solid you know
yeah she's solid well it's just a job to
her yeah she's not cheating on she he
she's real loyal to him and then she'll
do a gang bang on film and he's filming
it and [__] [__] yeah well like I
said they're not doing anything behind
each other they're not behind anything
back and that seriously he doesn't take
that serious like I said it's just a job
yeah like I said I get that right and
that's the thing it's just kind of
like I'm not I don't know I I I just
never been bothered by because I know
that you're a solid person you wouldn't
[__] me over I wouldn't [__] you over if
I was going to [__] you over I would
have done it already that's what I mean
like we've been together for so long and
you never [__] me over in all that time
I'm like well if you were going to do it
you would have done it by now you know
what I mean and I told you before it's
like I was married I was married for 14
years I never cheated on that dude yeah
ever yeah he thought I did this Mrs Lee
Story she says this I know this guy
before he married now he married he and
his he and his wife are sexless so she
gives him money to you know to go to the
[__] go go to the [__] hookers
okay then she goes He sometime call
me uh all that you know I kind of listen
listen for him to complain about it
listen for him complains about it okay
because and they go he doesn't want to
call the escort or something he usually
call me to have a beer or two and listen
listen
to it's cuz he loves you oh yeah how old
are you Miss Lee you are age she must be
40s 50s maybe I would think yeah yeah he
wants a real Affair he wants a real he
wants he wants a good woman a good woman
to have an affair
with a friend that who understands his
have a understanding that's what he's
trying to do
Ian England said uh I'd say pick your
lifestyle if you're worried about a
girl's body count maybe you should look
at where you're looking for girls at
yeah that's another thing you'd be
surprised but like I said girls going to
church man they H well yeah but you have
to consider I don't know I would always
consider everyone's like specific
situation I'm not really all that
worried about like the number about it
like I said you know mine is you know
low I'm going to say like probably I
don't know if it's it's well below
average but it's below average for sure
yours is probably like average to high
average I would imagine I don't know I
never even talled them up I yeah I don't
even think I know what your number is
but just from what I know about I don't
know what my number is but like I said
you're in your 50s yeah and you were
single for a large portion of that time
yeah and and and I count sacks I I count
a
number okay just if if we if we came so
it may not have yeah if we had a sexual
encounter didn't necessarily mean that
that still counts it was well like I
said I think we talked about that
earlier because I think I said what my
body count was and then you said oh that
counts too I said oh well an atire yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh well an atire no
any kind of sexual contact I count okay
if you go anal on some chick that counts
well I mean obviously obviously that
counts if you're getting a given head
and it's [__] completed that counts
[__] all that [__] counted we were
just talking about this before
because here's something funny that
happened at Barbarella the club that
we're going to go to yeah Miss Le's 40
younger okay yeah we're like about a
decade or decade and a half older than
14 years older than you yeah but we had
a thing I don't we probably brought this
up on the show before yeah but we were
at Barbarella this was probably like a
year ago and our we have a friend I'm
not going to say what his name is we
have a friend who's our age but he looks
a lot older and he has a fiance did they
get married no they're married he's
married okay so he so he has a wife but
she's apparently like she doesn't want
to go out she's fine with him buying
escorts yeah so he buys escorts you
don't buy them you're ranom you're R
well you know yeah yeah yeah you know
what I mean yeah and takes them out to
the club yeah and so one time he comes
to the
bar um with this girl who is uh trans
yeah and she was like super cute I can't
I was trying to remember what her name
was cuz we talked to her for a while a
photo of
yeah we tal like not like you're saying
just no that wasn't it God damn it was
her [__] name she told me what her
name she passed for a while I did it
took me a few minutes I I talked to her
for a long time it took me a few minutes
and IO she seemed a little bit like a n
but she seemed nice though it it took me
a few minutes talking to her I was like
that's not a biological female so she
seemed way more into Tom and me yeah
than she did the person that had hired
her for the evening yeah so I'm like at
the bar getting another drink or
something like that and Tom comes
running up to me at the bar no no no no
no don't [__] okay and said oh you don't
want me to say no you say don't [__]
no no no no no don't talk about that
okay [__] yeah okay I'm a [__]
that she made a move on me and [__]
in the men's room and uh she said if I
wasn't working right now [__] I'd be
going home with you guys kind of deal
you know what I mean I just kind of
smoothing it over you know what I mean
uh what was her name God we were trying
to remember like before the kids we were
just talking about it before the show
and like I can't remember her goddamn
name I would in the men's room she went
in there after me yeah yeah she was
trying to like um she was trying to come
home yeah she trying to blow me yeah I
was like I was like no no no no
no in the cute and all but you know what
I mean [__] no and the what was [__]
God damn it so I went I so so I [__]
called called him the next day and I
says how the [__] did you where the [__]
did you be he's going cuz he I mean fair
play to Tom he immediately told me like
he ran out the bathroom and like I was
at the bar and like told me oh my God
like this just happened so it's like he
did tell me like I got he sent me a
photograph of her all right I got to pee
all right let me see if I can find that
photograph it's either in this phone or
the other phone um it took me took me a
while to realized that that wasn't a
biological
female uh if I see show you the
picture you you You' think it was a
biological female let me
see but she was
uh she was an
escort and I was kind of surprised cuz
my boy I didn't know uh that he he liked
um trans girls
but I was like what's up with that he
goes oh no I just liked her you know
like not so so I asked her to come with
me and I said and I said is that a
regular thing you and you and uh trans
girls and he's like no no I he goes when
I first saw her photograph I didn't know
she was trans and I says what kind of TR
what so what photograph was it he sent
me the photograph he got her off a
[__] a app called what's your
price which is a dating application
where you can meet someone who wants to
date and they will tell you how much
it's going to cost you to go on a date
with them they're not real escorts
though they're
just they're women that are very
desperate they a lot of times they're in
some kind of desperate Financial price
and there no sex is not guaranteed or
anything it's just
um the only thing that's guaranteed is
that they will go on a date with
you and uh the dudes that we're talking
about he's a business owner he's got a
lot of money he owns a bar
I don't have a picture of her on this
phone let me go look at the other phone
see if I got
her Jo where'd he
go did you just leave I had to go get
the other okay I came back in and I'm
like where' he go I tell story tell a
story of where he got her and [__] oh
right right
okay he sent me the photograph that she
was she was cute she seemed a little
crazy though yeah she was trying to like
recruit me into a um a witch cult I
think she was just trying to be cool
cool I yeah I think so too but she
seemed nice but she seemed like she was
kind of I [__]
store all this [__] kind of [__] in
case I ever have to [__] tell the
story he has like photos of have photos
going back [__]
decades which I don't even know where
got her got her see you still got
[Laughter]
her that's right yeah yeah I remember
that was her he only brought her one
time yeah like I said she seemed nice
but she seemed a little a little bit
crazy yeah and little bit that is not a
biological female she wanted like I said
look just like that in person she seemed
to she seemed to like want to um hang
with us yeah she wanted to hang out she
she wanted to go home with us yeah she
did yeah she was all about it what was
her name all about it God I can't
remember it's like weird before the show
I was like for some reason I want to say
Shelly but it wasn't that it wasn't that
no there's Pooky what's up poke pants
you want to be on the show for a second
yeah everybody wants to see you Lin
Lee's still here she wants to see L here
she wants to see the Poke pants there's
Pooky your name is Miss Pooky pants Ross
that's your middle name is pants yeah
yeah Miss poy
pants yeah we have to go though yeah we
do we got holy [__] we're what is their
what is their reaction
to but no that was was a a high-end
trans
girl well yeah like she was I can't
remember but it's just it was so funny
because it was just funny that you came
out like after at the bar and you was
like oh my God she like tried to suck my
dick in the bathroom yeah yeah yeah and
I was just like what
yeah she got a little overzealous let
push me up against the wall and [__] and
started [__] unbuckling and getting
on her knees hold on hey she's going if
I wasn't working [__] I'm going home
with both of y'all you guys are so
[__] hot no no no no what are you
doing man what are you doing no no girl
come on come up here [__] you
know Jen's right out there man [__]
you know what I mean you can't [__]
do this [__] you know what's my
girlfriend gonna say oh no she's gonna
be all about it
[__] I'm gonna do her too [__] you
know yeah she really wanted a she wanted
a she wanted a piece of both of yeah she
wanted to get get in the middle of a Tom
and Jenny sandwich uhhuh yeah we get
that a lot I'm not really sure why that
is but you know what do they say and
what's their reaction oh everybody sound
like
Pooky yeah uh Heidi cor said she is
beautiful but definitely get the crazy
eye Vibe yeah yeah yeah I don't know if
she was as crazy as she was I think she
was just trying to like blend in and
like trying to be like like o I'm in
this Wiccan cult and all like Satanism
and all this kind of kind of stuff and
I'm just like okay but you know it was
that kind of stuff it was that kind of
stuff she seemed nice though she seemed
really nice I just I always thought that
was funny that she like corn she's hot
man so bathe
her I don't know happened to her he only
brought her one time he brings a
different one like every time he told me
she moved away oh okay he brings a
different one every time and sometimes
it's funny cuz he always like hires one
to come to Saturday nights which are
like ' 80s New Wave so you can tell that
he like cuz he likes them young okay and
he's our age actually yeah he's in his
50s so he'll bring one that's like
20 yeah and they're and they're just
like not about it that that trans girl
was in her 20s like 22 23 yeah she was
super young yeah she was super young
well like I said he likes him young yeah
which is a little weird but okay I mean
they're they're consenting I guess [__]
was that chick's name I can't I know
it's like no it's like no that was the
other that was the other trans girl that
we knew yeah yeah yeah okay her name was
Jess we got to go yeah we really got to
go we got to go to momentum Morty night
um it opens at 10:00 uh well there's not
going to be anybody there until later
but we'll see what do okay so we gotta
go uh thank you for hanging out with us
this evening having a drink with us
talking about [__] like we usually
do we'll be back on Monday for a movie
review don't know what movie it is we
haven't watched it yet so you'll be a
surprise as we are um so yeah thanks for
super chats thanks for hanging out and
we will see you guys again on Monday
good night